[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur public sénat édition spéciale sur
notre antenne ce matin c'est le jour j
pour la haute assemblée avec la
présentation du rapport de la commission
d' enquête du sénat sur la sphère
benalla après sept mois de travaux 34
audition philippe bas le président de la
commission des lois
accompagné de muriel jourda et jean
pierre sueur les deux co rapporteurs
vont dévoiler lors d'une conférence de
presse les conclusions de leur enquête
elle concerne vous le savez les
dysfonctionnements observés au plus haut
sommet de l'état
mais les sénateurs doivent aussi dire
s'il engage des poursuites à l'encontre
d'alexandre benalla soupçonnée d'avoir
menti sous serment
hasard du calendrier l'ancien chargé de
mission de l'elysée a passé sa première
nuit en prison
il a été placé en détention provisoire
hier pour non respect de son contrôle
judiciaire
c'est un énième rebondissement qui vient
un peu plus ce qui monte ce feuilleton
que nous allons analyser et commenter ce
matin avec mes invités j'ai plaisir
d'accueillir denis baranger bonjour
merci d'être avec nous professeur de
droit public à l'université panthéon
assas paris 2 bienvenue à vous également
sur ce plateau fabrice arfi merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation êtes
journaliste à mediapart et co
responsable du pôle enquête et puis jean
philippe derosier est également avec
nous vous êtes constitutionnaliste
bonjour professeur de droit public à
l'université de lille 1
on va d'ailleurs aussi retrouver ta
famille qui va nous faire vivre cette
conférence de presse
côté coulisses timbres que peut-on
attendre ce matin à des préconisations
des sénateurs d' a écouté delphine on
parle d'un rapport de 145 pages de 13
recommandations
le rapporteur c'est à dire le socialiste
jean-pierre sueur et la sénatrice les
républicains muriel jourda ont peaufiné
jusqu'à hier la moindre formulation du
rapport les sénateurs jugent au niveau
du constat qu'il y a eu des défaillances
de l'état que l'exécutif a beaucoup trop
faiblement sanctionnée alexandre benalla
après les événements du 1er mai est
beaucoup trop tardivement est la
commission denquête juge aussi que
benalla a bien exercer une mission de
protection du président de la république
pour eux il y a eu ingérence dans la
sécurité du président de la république
alexandre benalla à essayer de
réorganiser les services de sécurité
pour les déconnecter du ministère de
l'intérieur la commission denquête doit
faire des recommandations pour que tous
les dysfonctionnements constatés à
travers cette affaire au sein de l'état
ne se reproduise pas ils doivent
notamment réaffirmé qu'il faut confier
la sécurité du président de la
république uniquement à la force
publique
enfin nous savons que philippe bas a
parlé ce matin de faux témoignages
d'ailleurs il faut dire que depuis
plusieurs semaines plusieurs sénateurs
vente affirmé que alexandre benalla
avait menti sous serment qu'il les avait
mené en bateau si tu peux lire alors
jusqu'à cinq ans de prison et 75000
euros d'amendé
la commission denquête peut donc signalé
à la justice ces soupçons de parjure
devant devant les sénateurs
merci beaucoup et âme pour tout à ces
précisions et alexandre poussard est
également présent alexandre ce matin il
ya beaucoup de journalistes sur place il
faut dire que c'est le point d'orgue des
travaux de la commission d' enquête du
sénat
oui défi le point d'orgue de ces travaux
et il ya derrière moi la salle
clémenceau la salle où va se dérouler
cette conférence de presse de la
commission d'enquêté c'est dans cette
salle que se sont déroulées les 34
auditions de la commission denquête
benalla depuis le mois de juillet alors
pour le moment les sénateurs sont réunis
dans les étages du sénat a laissé dans
les salles de la commission des lois et
ses îles sont réunis depuis 8 heures ce
matin et les deux rapporteurs de la
commission denquête leur ont présenté le
rapport
les sénateurs ont évoqué les principales
propositions de ce rapport ce cas il est
bien évidemment bien évidemment
impossible d'étudier chaque ligne de ce
rapport qui fait 145 pages il va ensuite
avoir une délibération et puis un vote
des sénateurs de la commission des lois
pour ou contre ce rapport ce vote
devrait être logiquement favorable
et puis permettre donc la conférence de
presse des deux co rapporteurs et du
président de la commission des lois
il y a pour l'instant des dizaines de
journalistes qui attendent à l'extérieur
de cette salle on sait que à peu près 80
journalistes sont accrédités pour
assister à cette conférence de presse
je peux vous dire que les synthèse du
rapport sont déjà prêtes dans cette
salle
chaque synthèse est sur la table et
attend les journalistes et donc il va
on attend maintenant l'arrivée du
président et des deux corps des deux co
rapporteurs pour le que la conférence de
presse commence dans maintenant moins de
30 minutes
merci beaucoup alexandre pour toutes vos
précisions alors je vous le disais
alexandre bénazet dans son crayon été
placé hier soir en détention provisoire
les deux hommes sont soupçonnés d'avoir
violé leur contrôle judiciaire il avait
en effet interdiction de rentrer en
contact
or les enregistrements révélés par
mediapart ou état du contraire quand on
call me sur ces images on peut voir
alexandre benalla arrivé libre au
tribunal de paris
face au juge des libertés et de la
détention une audience s'est tenue dans
la soirée parquet et juge d'instruction
demande le placement en détention
provisoire de l'ancien chargé de mission
ainsi que de vincent kraz en sont
responsables de la sécurité dans marche
en cause la rencontre du 26 juillet dont
mediapart a diffusé les enregistrements
[Musique]
problème depuis le 22 juillet ils sont
tous les deux mis en examen et ont
interdiction de se voir
il ya donc là selon les magistrats une
violation du contrôle judiciaire hier
soir le juge a donc décidé de placer
alexandre benalla et vincent kraz en
détention provisoire
une décision dénoncée par l'avocate de
l'ex chargé de mission oui je suis en
colère parce que alexandre dellal a rien
à faire en 13 ans avec son bel halal a
jamais été condamné
alexandre bédat à 27 ans il un bébé de 6
mois
il a fait de garde à vue il est venu
plusieurs fois chez les juges il ya
toujours des ferré et aujourd'hui sur le
fondement d'extrait d' écoutes
téléphoniques coupées
produit par médiapart dont nous ne sont
pas lutter contre lesquels le parquet a
déposé une plainte
on incarcère aujourd'hui pour une
prétendue concertation qui aurait lu il
ya sept mois tout cela est ridicule et
je dis qu'effectivement la justice sous
pression même pas une bonne justice et
je trouve ça profondément se font moins
juste un rebondissement judiciaire qui
intervient alors que de nouvelles
poursuites pourraient bientôt être
engagée dans le dossier les sénateurs
pourraient saisir le parquet sur les
soupçons de parjure contre alexandre
bénin
cette détention provisoire c'est un
énième rebondissement fabrice arfi ça
vient pimenter un peu plus ce feuilleton
déjà tentaculaire ça devenait inévitable
cette détention
abbas et le choix des magistrats c'est
plusieurs magistrats c'est le parquet
qui a souhaité la détention provisoire
les juges d'instruction de la sphère des
violences du 1er mai dans le cadre de
laquelle alexandre benalla et vincent
brazon violé leur contrôle judiciaire au
mois de juillet dernier on souhaitait
aussi cette détention et le juge des
libertés et de la détention le jld a
validé une finesse est cette détention
est une procédure judiciaire il aurait
pu ressortir libre il aurait pu avoir un
contrôle renforcé de un durcissement du
contrôle judiciaire ou aller en prison
c'est la décision qui a été prise pour
une raison simple ce avec les éléments
que mediapart a révélé montré que en
effet vous avez violé leur contrôle
judiciaire à l'occasion de cette
rencontre secrète
voilà on a entendu des extraits du 26
juillet en début d'après midi à paris
ils se sont rencontrés vincent kraz et
alexandre bédat l'a pas pour parler de
leur vie personnelle ou des matches du
psg
ils ont ils se sont rencontrés pour
comploter contre la justice pour
envisager des destructions preuve pour
changer notamment les montages
financiers de ce qui apparaît de mon
point de vue peut-être l'élément le plus
grave des différentes saisons de la
sphère benalla c'est la sphère des
contrats russe et donc tous ces éléments
ont pour les juges justifier le
placement en détention alors pour un
journal et pour un journaliste il ya
aucun d'aucune espèce de jubilation du
plaisir à savoir carmes article a pu
envoyer quelqu'un en prison mais notre
travail est de dire les faits et les
faits sont là jean-philippe and roses et
c'est vrai que ça donne un nouveau coup
de projecteur cette chute d'alexandre
bénin depuis sept mois comment vous
réagissez à ce placement en détention
provisoire
je je
mais pas vraiment à réagir à cela c'est
me semble-t-il parfaitement cadré par la
procédure
pas de pronostic à faire ou pas savoir
s'il allait il filme finir en détention
provisoire ou non comme monsieur arfi
vient de le rappeler il ya des faits
monsieur benalla a été mis en examen
début juillet il a été placé sous
contrôle judiciaire visiblement il a
violé son contrôle judiciaire est l'une
des possibilités en cas de violation du
contrôle judiciaire c'est le placement
en détention provisoire
le placement en détention provisoire se
justifier partir du moment où la justice
craint de ne pas pouvoir retrouver le
prévenu dans le cadre de l'anc est
craint des éventuelles destructions de
preuves et c est visiblement vu le
tempérament du personnage vu ce qui est
révélé par les enregistrements que vous
avez rendu public
eh bien on peut avoir un certain nombre
de craintes maintenant ça peut être
aussi une façon de formuler un
avertissement à monsieur bénalia
monsieur craint peut-être seront t-il
libérer un moment donné dans la
poursuite du procès c'est tout à fait
c'est tout à fait possible
maintenant on voit que cette affaire
qu'au départ ont qualifié d' affaires
d'été recèle un certain nombre de
ramifications qu'on découvre presque
chaque jour est effectivement la
question des financements étaient
contrat russe ainsi qu'on les appelle
est un énième épisode aujourd'hui sans
doute l'un des plus importants il y
avait aussi la question de la
construction d'une certaine sécurité je
ne peux pas parler de police parallèle
mais il y avait quand même des
interrogations si voilà au sein de
l'elysée donc aux 116 ressortir et est
donc juste pour terminer sur ce point
est donc effectivement
va toujours en avançant et on peut
comprendre que la justice veuille
prendre des précautions à ce niveau là
notant qu on apprend que des saunas ça
se confirme et si bien qu'il ya eu un
faux témoignage et rétention
d'informations c'est ce qui va être
présenté à la presse d'ici quelques
minutes de nuit baranger par urs est
extrêmement rare dans l'histoire du
sénat ces permis par la constitution ça
justement cette saisine de la justice
ça fait partie des prérogatives que ça
fait partie des prérogatives d'une
commission denquête comme d'ailleurs de
tout citoyen ou administrations sur la
base de l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale donc au fond là la
commission denquête alors il se trouve
que devant cette commission denquête le
parjure est sanctionné spécialement par
une infraction pénale particulière par
une amende jusqu'à cinq ans de prison
mais c'est simplement un des aspects des
résultats de cette commission denquête
qu'on aura nos quelques minutes dans
quelques instants
fabrice arfi ça se confirme je le disais
le sénat va donc saisir la justice pour
faire le témoignage réponse une
information aussi vous estimez bientôt
avec sandro benalla n'a pas tout dit
devancé commission d' enquête
parlementaire
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup
de suspense sur le fait qu'avec son bien
à la et vincent kraz et surtout
alexandre men alae menti devant les
sénateurs à plusieurs égards que ce soit
sur la question de l'organisation de
l'elysée de la construction non plus
j'aime pas comme vous le mot de police
parallèle peut-être brigade du chef de
passe de disruption sécuritaire que
benalla et ses amis ont voulu faire au
sein de l'elysée au profit personnel du
président de la république à l'abri
d'une sorte de parapluie d'impunité de
cave et monsieur benalla eu égard à sa
relation particulière avec le chef de
l'état mais aussi sur les contrats russe
monsieur benalla a menti nous en avons
administré la preuve dans plusieurs
enquêtes de mediapart ou sur les
passeports diplomatiques pour moi la
question est plutôt de savoir si la le
soupçon de parjure va être étendu à
d'autres personnes que alexandre benalla
et vincent kraz est-ce que ça va
concerner des fonctionnaires est ce que
ça va concerner éventuellement je n'en
sais rien j'ai pas d'information des
gens de l'elysée qui ont témoigné devant
la commission
de mon point de vue l'enjeu se situe
plutôt là ce matin
on va peut-être en savoir plus avec tam
tran huy a toujours un foyer à
clemenceau salon commence à avoir
quelques informations sur ce rapport
très attendu ce matin oui sur leur
rapport et notamment sur le fait
également ce matin philippe bas à bien
parler de faux témoignages et qu'il a
annoncé bien souhaité saisir la justice
il a parlé de trois points ce matin et
il a parlé de ses photos de témoignages
mais aussi d'intervention d'information
qui ont été retenus lors de ces
témoignages a priori bien le président
de la commission des lois ne pointent du
doigt qu'alexandre benalla bien qu' il y
ait pu avoir de nombreux faux témoignage
lors de cette commission denquête on
parle d' alexandre benalla de vincent
kraz sur la question d'alexandrie n'a là
il ya les passeports diplomatiques
le contrat un russe le fait qu'il ait
revu vincent kraz on n'a pas encore les
précisions sur exactement quel point
sont ciblés par philippe bas en tout cas
et bien ce cas va être a priori transmis
au bureau du sénat
c'est un cas très rare je rappelle qu'il
ya une seule fois une commission
d'enquêté qui a bien transmis un cas de
parjure en 2016 au bureau du sénat
ce bureau composé de 26 sénateurs peut
ensuite demandé au président du sénat de
saisir le parquet et c'est donc gérard
larcher au final qui va décider de
saisir la justice
gérard larcher qui ce matin a dit se
tenir prêt merci beaucoup
tam alors justement on évoquer cette
question des contrats russe je propose
de revenir justement sur ce qu'on peut
attendre de ce rapport avec quentin
calme et très attendue depuis des mois
c'est aujourd'hui à 11 heures que les
sénateurs rendront enfin leurs
conclusions dans la tentaculaire affaire
banale un point de départ pour la
commission denquête les violences de la
place de la contrescarpe le monde révèle
le 18 juillet l'identité d'alexandre
benalla s'ensuivront 29 auditions dont
celle de l'ancien chargé de mission avec
un constat qui apparaît au fil des
témoignages
alexandre benalla a désorganisé les
services de l'état en ce qui concerne
monsieur ben alla je ne suis toujours
pas convaincu qu'il n'exerçait pas la
fonction de garde du corps
comment expliquer autrement le port
d'armes
mais en décembre la sphère est relancée
lors d'une visite
des manuels maquereau au tchad on
apprend qu alexandre benalla à continuer
à utiliser des passeports diplomatiques
alors qu'il n'était plus salariée de
l'elysée les sénateurs décide alors
d'organiser cinq nouvelles auditions
quand il va voir le prés le frère du
président du tchad qui a un rôle éminent
matière de sécurité et d'importation
d'armes au tchad et qu'il le fait avec
un passeport officiel on peut quand même
s'interroger sur le rôle réel de mathieu
benhaddad dans une diplomatie parallèle
aux soupçons de diplomatie parallèle
s'ajoutent ensuite le volet sur les
contrats russe il aurait été négocié
pour l'un d'entre eux au moins alors
qu'alexandre benalla était encore
salarié l'elysée je voulais vous
demander si vous connaissiez monsieur
iskander makhmoudov
je ne connais pas cette personne nous à
part à travers la presse je ne les ai
jamais rencontrés
une réponse prononcée alors qu'alexandre
benalla était sous serment
de nombreux sénateurs le suspecte alors
d'avoir commis un parjure
il nous a menti en tout cas la
commission en décidera mais
manifestement ému a menti et sûrement
pas qu'une seule fois donc on va
prospecter en la matière si nous sommes
intimement convaincus qu'ils aient eu
mensonge en tout cas ça c'est mon intime
conviction personnelle
nous devons demander à la justice de
sanctionner mme dhalla sur tous ses
volets de la sphère benalla les
conclusions les sénateurs sont donc très
attendus voilà et on connaîtra les
conclusions d'ici un petit quart d'heure
on voit déjà les rapports sur ces images
proposées par notre réalisateur filme de
sony on voit que les rapports sont prêts
ils sont dans cette salle clemenceau
pour donc être distribué aux
journalistes restent préposition
préconisations pardon l oms philippe
derosier avec le sénat dont qui va être
très attaché à savoir quelle était la
fonction exacte c'est là aussi le coeur
de cette commission denquête la fonction
exercée par alexandre ben alaoui la
commission denquête porte précisément
sur l'organisation et la participation
des personnes qui n'appartiennent pas
aux forces de l'ordre pour la sécurité
des très hautes personnalités et du
président de la république et donc une
commission denquête enquête sur des
faits ce n'est pas une enquête
judiciaire ce n'est pas une enquête de
police elle est là pour enquêter sur des
fonctionnement administratif et donc
enquêter sur des faits
elle va éventuellement révélées sûr
qu'elle va étudier et qui vont lui
permettre le cas échéant de faire des
recommandations des propositions pour
des évolutions des réformes des
modifications et dans cette question
apparaît évidemment monsieur alexandre
benalla et son rôle précis au sein de
l'elysée il est normalement chargés de
mission adjoint au chef de cabinet mais
on a entendu le président bahaa dire que
il se pourrait bien qu'il ait été garde
du corps donc essayer de comprendre de
comprendre tout cela et ensuite ce n'est
qu'un élément parallèle de la commission
denquête de s'interroger sur quelle est
la teneur de la laquelle elle à la
véracité des auditions des propos qui
ont été tenus devant elle
et si ils ont des doutes ce n'est pas
eux qui poursuivent un ce n'est pas eux
qui vont poursuivre ce n'est pas eux qui
vont condamner le président de la
commission denquête enfin plus
exactement de la commission des lois
toujours monsieur philippe bas va
pouvoir décider de transmettre le
dossier au procureur qui décidera ou non
d'engager des poursuites le président
dira simplement nous pensons que telles
et telles personnes nous ont menti et
c'est pénalement répréhensible ça aussi
vous l'avez rappelé cinq ans
d'emprisonnement 75000 euros d'amendé et
le procureur décidera ou non d'engager
des poursuites s'il le fait la justice
décidera ou non de condamner les
personnes qui auraient commis un parjure
denis marange est important de dire que
effectivement ce n'est pas une
commission d' enquête judiciaire on est
là dans une mission de contrôle
parlementaire pendant sept mois la du
marché un peu sur des oeufs
cette commission dont elle pour ne pas
empiéter le travail de la justice ça lui
a été d'ailleurs reproché un ça lui a
été reprochée avant la bataille si je
puis dire par la garde des sceaux elle
même madame belloubet qui s'était
inquiété d'une violation de la
séparation des pouvoirs
elle avait peut-être raison de son
inquiéter la réalité ne lui a pas donné
raison à mon sens parce que la
commission denquête a été très habile et
très disciplinée elle n'a jamais posé de
questions qui empiétait sur l' enquête
judiciaire est bien au contraire elle a
insisté à la porte et le faire sur la
question des dysfonctionnements
institutionnels parce qu'en réalité
comme ça a été dit c'est pas une mission
d' enquête sur monsieur benalla ni sur
quiconque
c'est sûr le problème institutionnel à
l'intérieur de l'elysée la mise à
l'écart des services officiels de
protection du président de la république
et puis des relations de l'elysée avec
le reste de l'administration donc c'est
sur ces dysfonctionnements
institutionnels qu'on attend ce rapport
senna essentiellement parce que la
mission de la commission denquête c'est
de s'informer sur le fonctionnement de
l'état avant tout des formuler des
préconisations disait fabrice arfi sur
justement qui doit gérer cette sécurité
est de rapprocher un du père oui en fait
c'est ça peut paraître pour plein de
citoyens une question assez lointaine la
sécurité du président en fait c'est une
question absolument fondamentales
concernant la protection du chef de
l'état concernant la protection du pays
de la nation le chef de l'état français
ne peut pas avoir des faiblesses qui
peuvent être exploitées physiquement
mais pas qu'eux physiquement par
l'extérieur de l'elysée y compris par
des puissances étrangères c'est pour ça
qu'ils à un groupement de sécurité du
président de la république le gspr est
ce que nous révèle entre autres les
saisons de la sphère benalla c'est qu'il
y avait eu une volonté de privatiser et
de mettre à l'écart les services
officiels pour que alexandre benallal
constitue une sorte de brigade du chef à
lui avec tout un une escouade de
réservistes de l'armée de la gendarmerie
pour protéger à sa manière et on sait ce
qui est depuis maintenant le mois de mai
et l'été dernier sa manière le président
de la république quand on sait à
fortiori que cet homme alors qu'il était
à l'elysée alors qu'ils étaient par
fonction dépositaire d'informations
confidentielles de la présidence de la
république alors qu'ils étaient
habilités au secret défense pendant
qu'il travaillait à la présidence de la
république il négocier des contrats de
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
avec des oligarques proche de vladimir
poutine et qui pour l'un d'entre eux est
soupçonné par plusieurs magistrats
européens d'être lié au pire groupes
criminels et mafieux d'eau moscou alors
la sécurité intérieure le parquet
national à financer bien sûr qui a
ouvert une enquête pour corruption mais
ça pose également la question d'un
risque de compromission au sommet de
l'état c'est une affaire d' ingérence
russe potentiel comme on en connaît dans
d'autres pays et dans d'autres pays
notamment les états unis il ya un
procureur spécial qui a été désigné avec
70 enquêteurs du fbi aille très avocat
pour sécuriser la procédure qui
travaillent sur sur ce dossier c'est
évidemment la faire de l'ingérence russe
de monsieur trump donc là on est au
coeur non pas de la protection d'un
homme président de la république mais de
la nation après sa finale je vous
interromps on est toujours en édition
spéciale sur public sénat on attend
bien la présentation de ce rapport de la
commission d enquête parlementaire sur
la sphère benalla on va ça le clemenceau
d'un tout de suite vous êtes alexandre
poussard on voit les journalistes
commencent à arriver et on voit ces
rapports derrière vous c'est précieux
rapport le secret a été tenue bien de
façon très soigneuse jusqu'à ce matin
alexandre mais oui delphine ces précieux
rapport ces rapports qui ont été qui ont
été terminés d'être rédigée à peu près
lundi soir ils ont été tenus secrets
dans la journée d'hier et de maintenant
ils sont ils sont imprimés ils sont
prêts ils sont bien ficelés alors il ya
à la fois un rapport complet est d'à peu
près 145 pages et puis il ya des
synthèse du rapport pour permettre le
traitement des journalistes alors pour
l'instant
évidemment on ne peut pas les ouvrir ils
sont tenus secrets et la commission des
lois est actuellement réuni dans les
étages du sénat pour délibérer approuver
ou non
le rapport des deux co rapporteurs de la
commission denquête benalla et si jamais
ce rapport n'est pas approuvée par la
commission des lois
eh bien tous ces textes resteront
secrets et retourneront dans les bureaux
de la commission donc oui vous le disiez
pour l'instant les journalistes
commencent à entrer dans cette salle
clemenceau pour cette conférence de
presse 80 journalistes sont attendus à
peu près pour cette conférence de presse
sur la sphère benalla alexandre son film
de rose et on disait qu'elle a quand
même gêné cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire du sénat encore ce matin
un déclaration d'oran berger députés en
mars ce qui me disaient que cela crée un
précédent dangereux le sénat a voulu
faire de la politique nous dit elle oui
le sénat a voulu faire de la politique
je crois me souvenir que c'est une
institution politique que c'est l'une
des deux chambres du parlement et que
faire de la politique c'est très
précisément son rôle
alors si madame berger considère que
effectivement remplir des missions
politiques c'est dangereux peut-être
faudrait-il qu'elle réfléchisse à sa
propre fonction et si elle trouve que la
démocratie parlementaire et dangereuse
effectivement on peut comprendre cette
logique qui est de vouloir réduire le
nombre de parlementaires pour la pousser
jusqu'à son terme et pourquoi pas
souvent la supprimer le parlement
effectivement
elle a gêné et vous avez tout à fait
citer la garde des sceaux qui au début
de la sphère avait publié une tribune
dans le journal le monde il y avait eu
aussi le fameux coup de fil du président
de la république mm macro au président
du sénat gérard larcher lui demandant
d'essayer de contrôler ses services et
ses commissions d'enquêté ces sénateurs
pour éviter qu'ils le fassent leur
travail ce qui est tout à fait
scandaleux
1 il ya une logique de contre-pouvoir le
parlement exerce un contrôle sur le
gouvernement et le pouvoir exécutif et
la commission denquête la commission des
lois dotée des pouvoirs d'enquêté a
parfaitement rempli rempli ce rôle une
fois attendre l'automne pour qu'il y ait
une
un changement de ton de la part de
l'exécutif avec benjamin griveaux qui a
commencé à reconnaître un débit
fonctionnement qui peuvent je suis
choquée a les français c'est ce que nous
disait le porte-parole du gouvernement
de mélanger oui fabrice arfi a dit à
plusieurs saisons comme dans les séries
télévisées il ya eu d'abord les
violences du 1er mai on pouvait encore
un petit peu masqué ce qui s'était passé
il ya eu ensuite les passeports
diplomatiques c'est devenu beaucoup plus
difficile le travail de la commission
sénatoriale qui a apporté un certain
nombre de faits un petit peu
problématique
et puis maintenant la sphère des
contrats russe comme vous dites c'est un
peu le le virus dans l'ordinateur cette
affaire là c'est la manière de rentrer
au sommet de l'état pour un certain
nombre de gens donc au fond on voit
comment le travail de la commission
sénatoriale ça a été un travail de
contre pouvoirs et contre-pouvoirs ça se
déplace maintenant on a une opposition
qui est forte au sénat la majorité du
sénat et l'opposition président de la
république pour le moment ce le sénat
fait son travail de contre-pouvoir ça
changerait dans une autre configuration
politique quelques semaines après le
sénat refusait de faire une commission
d' enquête sur la pédophilie dans
l'église catholique
on aurait pu s'interroger sur les
raisons pourquoi il refusait de le faire
c'est maintenant l'église qui a sa
propre commission dans quatre billets
les la question des contre-pouvoirs
c'est une question de déplacement
permanent c'est évidemment que ça gêne
parce que c'est fait pour c'est pour ça
que le bicamérisme est précieux moi je
suis
très sincèrement sidérés stupéfaits
d'entendre qu'une responsables
politiques comme aurore bergé puisse
considérer comme un précédent dangereux
le fait que la démocratie fonctionne ça
en dit long sur chez certaines personnes
un déficit culturel quant à ce qui est
en démocratie les contre-pouvoirs on va
pas rendre la justice sur quelques
aspects mais ne remet pas la justice
ils contrôlent ils contrôlent c'est une
fonction constitutionnel il contrôle
l'exécutif et la présidence de la
république c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne la démocratie la séparation
des pouvoirs contrairement à ce qu'avait
écrit notamment madame b loubet c'est
pas la liberté donnée à chaque pouvoir
de faire ce qu'il veut dans son coin
celle inverse
l'un des pères de la nation et je parle
sous le contrôle personnes me présente
autour de la table l'un des pères de la
nation française montesquieu dans
l'esprit des lois nous a clairement
indiqué que je cite par la disposition
des choses le pouvoir doit arrêter le
pouvoir pour éviter les abus du pouvoir
c'est exactement ce qui se passe et que
aujourd'hui et des responsables
politiques qui viennent instiller le
doute dans l'esprit des citoyens parce
que c'est ce que fait madame aurore
bergé en disant que quand le sénat fait
son travail c'est un précédent dangereux
bah oui oui la démocratie ça peut être
dangereux pour ceux qui font des bêtises
et encore heureux c'est un tranquille ça
n'est pas un cortège de pétales de roses
ça n'est pas son mauvais jeu de mots le
passeport donner à l'exécutif pour faire
ce qu'il veut quand il veut où il veut
ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça voilà et
donc ça n'est pas je trouve vraiment je
le dis sereinement mais pas tolérable
d'entendre des choses comme ça dans
notre démocratie d'un film oui on a on a
un parlement qui est bicaméral une
première chambre l'assemblée nationale
dans laquelle règne ce que l'on appelle
le fait majoritaire c'est à dire
l'existence d'une majorité claire stable
qui va soutenir durablement l'exécutif
le gouvernement dans la durée de la
législature cinq ans et c'est une bonne
chose pour la démocratie parce que ça
véhicule de la stabilité ça permet au
gouvernement de gouverner de prendre les
décisions pendant le temps qui lui est
imparti
mais il est nécessaire qu'il y ait un
contre-pouvoir et ce contre-pouvoir
parlementaire existe très précisément au
sénat effectivement ça ennuie sans kiki
quand on veut faire une révision
constitutionnelle le sénat n'est pas
toujours d'accord quand on veut
contrôler l'exécutif et ben le sénat
parfois met son grain de sel bon mais
c'est très bien ainsi parce que s'il n'y
avait eu que l'assemblée nationale elle
a été dotée également des pouvoirs
d'enquêté pouvoir d'une commission
denquête pendant un mois seulement c'est
à dire pendant mois d'août sait très
bien qu'en france en général au mois
d'août il se passe pas grand chose
la mangue debol effectivement il ya eu
cette affaire qui a éclaté
mais cette commission denquête a explosé
en plein vol comme on le dit parce que
il y avait effectivement cette volonté
de soutenir l'exécutif de soutenir de
protéger le président de la république
c'est son rôle à l'assemblée nationale 1
de lui faciliter la tâche
mais qui a été donc incapable de mener
objectivement une commission denquête au
sénat la commission des lois présidée
par philippe bas avec deux rapporteurs
de deux bords politiques opposées
socialistes et républicains ont mené un
travail minutieux ils ont utilisé la
plénitude de leurs six mois à
disposition et sans attaque politique
autre que le rôle politique que doit
accomplir le parlement le sénat dans sa
mission de contrôle qui est
constitutionnellement reconnu par
l'article 24 de la constitution va
retrouver un thème trani puisqu'on
commence à avoir d'autres éléments de ce
rapport m
oui effectivement delphine et a priori
contrairement à ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure
et bien la transmission à la justice
pourrait être un peu plus large que ce
que l'on pouvait imaginer
le président de la commission des lois
parlerait de parjure devant la
commission denquête je vous rappelle que
ces cinq ans de prison et 75000 euros
d'amendé
il parlerait aussi de retenue
d'information est donc là la liste des
protagonistes serait un petit peu plus
large alors bien sûr on parle d'
alexandre benalla mais il serait aussi
question du témoignage d'alexis colère
le secrétaire général de l'elysée de
celui de patrick strzoda le
directeur de cabinet des manuels macron
on nous parle également de vincent kra
zain qui était un côté d'alexandre
benalla place de la contrescarpe et
enfin du colonel lionel à lavernhe le
patron du gspr tout cela est bien sûr à
prendre au conditionnel delphine voilà
et bien à l'état de nos dernières
informations
merci beaucoup tam effectivement d
information à prendre au conditionnel
mais qui risque de jeter une lumière
encore plus importante sur ces deux
travaux du sénat denis branger
oui c'est très intéressant ce qui se
passe là parce que si les parjures et
les déferrement au parquet son étendue
au delà de monsieur bénard la crise
institutionnelle va s'accentuer va y
avoir probablement plus de changements à
l'elysée qu'on connaît en attendaient y
aura pas seulement bien qui est qui et
qui est partie probablement disent les
journalistes compétents sur la base de
cette de cette affaire-là la crise un
sujet à la baisse accentuée spécialement
car il écrit un livre absolument
mais c'est certainement vrai aussi moi
je pense que c'est assez intéressant
cette affaire là parce que ça montre le
problème que pose l'irresponsabilité
politique du président de la république
quand il dit qu'on vienne me chercher
sur cette affaire car il sait très bien
qu'on ne peut pas aller le chercher
et en réalité ça le fragilise lui
laissera fadli son entourage quand
l'assemblée nationale a mal géré cette
affaire de sa propre commission d'
enquête qui a qui a échoué je me suis
dit médiatement que c'était mauvais pour
l'assemblée nationale même que c'était
mauvais pour la république en marche et
pour l'elysée si on avait géré cette
affaire là comme un problème
institutionnel même pour le président et
même pour l'elysée peut-être que les
hauts fonctionnaires qui ont été mis
dans la lumière alors que c'est pas leur
rôle d'être mis dans la lumière et qui
maintenant vont faire l'objet
d'accusations alors que globalement ils
ont été sur ordre izon ils ont dit
monsieur colère et monsieur strauss
zarandy qu'il venait sur la permission
du président avec pardon avec la
permission du président de la république
donc ce qu'ils ont dit lille 17 heures
ils étaient en mission peut-être ont-ils
commis des parjures ou non je peux pas
en juger si la commission dit c'est très
fort là la crise institutionnelle va
s'accentuer je peux vous le garantir
on est dans une affaire d'état fabrice
arfi beaucoup de sénateurs l'ont dit ça
passe ça d'une affaire n'était pour
reprendre votre expression à cette
affaire d'état je crois que les
ingrédients de ce qu'on peut appeler une
affaire d'état après il s'agit pas de se
bercer de mou
voilà mais je crois que les ingrédients
sont en effet réunis on parle des
dysfonctionnements majeurs de la
présidence de la république de la
sixième puissance mondiale de la
possible privatisation de la sécurité du
président la république des
dysfonctionnements à la préfecture de
police au ministère de l'intérieur au
quai d'orsay de l' usage d'une possible
diplomatie parallèle où monsieur benalla
va rencontrer plusieurs chefs d'état
africains dans une sorte de voyage
françafricain à l'automne dernier et je
leur dis de liens d'affaires de
dépendance d'un homme au coeur de
l'elysée et de ses secrets avec des
oligarques proche de vladimir poutine
bon si certains ne veulent pas y voir
les éléments d'un d'une affaire d'état
tant pis pour eux c'est les informations
venaient à être confirmés que les
parjures et la rétention d'information
devait s'élargir à d'autres personnes et
notamment à des représentants de
l'elysée alors oui la sphère benalla
prendrait encore plus les atours d'un
scandale politique majeure et ce n' est
plus une affaire benalla dont il faut
parler à mon sens mais une affaire
macron benalla puisque on ne peut pas
désincarcérer si vous me permettez
l'expression alexandre benalla de
l'elysée du parapluie d'impunité que lui
a fourni la présidence de la république
et le président de la république
personnellement tout à l'heure vous
citiez la phrase de benjamin griveaux à
l'automne dernier qui disait il ya des
dysfonctionnements que ça mais au mois
de novembre dernier le président de la
république lui-même emmanuel macron au
micro de nos confrères d'europe 1
réclamé l'indulgence judiciaire pour
alexandre benalla au mois de novembre
on est bien après le 1er mai donc on
voit bien la kia est depuis plus un mot
plus un mot le pool le président de la
république qui a peur à juste titre de
l'ingérence rues dans tout un pan de la
société française d'information les
gilet jaune etc cela n'a pas un mot
nulle part jamais sur ce qui s'est passé
avec les contrats de monsieur benalla
concernant la russie
ça ne manque pas de surprendre ce
silence embarrassé gêné aux entournures
de la présidence de la république face à
chacun des faits et gestes de ce
personnage
alexandre banal a été auditionné en deux
fois par les sénateurs pour lui et bien
on a voulu faire de lui un personnage
sulfureux c'est ce qu'il avait dit lors
de sa deuxième audition je vous propose
de l'écouter tout de suite en six mois
on a réussi à construire et à faire de
moi un personnage qu'on dise sulfureux
diabolique infréquentable enfin ce sont
tous les qualificatifs qui sont employés
à mon encontre et je pense de manière
très modeste avoir contribué à la
construction de ce personnage de par des
propos que j'ai pu tenir qui ont été
situés hors de leur contexte mais aussi
de par parfois mon attitude quitté qui a
peut-être été jugée décalé et je je je
le conçois que j'ai pu donner une
mauvaise image de moi mais je tenais
devant vous monsieur le président à
remettre dans le contexte cette pseudo
affaire benalla où on a bien vu le
cheminement la construction
médiatico-politique qui n'avaient qu'un
seul but atteindre le président de la
république
je pense que ça a marché et j'espère que
ça va se terminer assez rapidement pour
mon pays et pour la réussite que je
souhaite au président de la république
voilà c'était le 21 janvier jean
philippe derosier ça ça confirme ce que
je disais à l'instant
fabrice arfi on a voulu attendre le
président emmanuel macron nous dit
alexandre benalla à travers moi ou plus
exactement le président de la république
s'est laissé atteindre à travers lui je
crois que c'est davantage cela parce que
effectivement on parler affaires d'été
ou affaire d'état et tout le monde
connaît je pense autour de cette table
et les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent ce célèbre tableau de magritte
ceci n'est pas une pipe
ceci n'est pas une affaire d'état mais
il ya un certain nombre d'éléments qui
laissent supposer que ça représenterait
une affaire d'état et vous les avez vous
les avez justement cité le premier point
qu'on est droite sur lequel on est en
droit de s'interroger c'est que monsieur
benalla a commis des faits
répréhensibles le 1er mai dès le 1er mai
au soir où le 2 mai les services de
l'elysée sont informés
y compris la plus haute hiérarchie à
savoir le directeur de cabinet patrick
strzoda qui est préfet qui a une longue
expérience de l'administration est une
expérience politique
contrairement à d'autres personnes qui
fréquentent le palais de l'elysée et dès
le 2 mai aucune ou presque sanction
n'est prise
en tout cas pas de licenciement de ce
monsieur qui occupe quand même une
fonction importante adjoint au chef de
cabinet cela signifie quoi je veux pas
tourner autour du pot cela signifie tout
simplement qu'il est protégé et il est
nécessairement protégé au plus haut
niveau le plus bas du plus haut ce
serait par patrick strzoda lui-même vue
les auditions qu'il a pu tenir
on en doute donc ça veut dire que c'est
à un niveau encore plus élevé est au
dessus de patrick strzoda dans la
hiérarchie n'y a que deux personnes
alexis colère le secrétaire général de
l'elysée et le président de la
république et donc le président de
république est nécessairement informés
de quelque chose comme ça ou alors c'est
que verizon les tables mantoue
dysfonctionne et ça je ne peux pas y
croire
et si monsieur alexandre reynal art
reste à l'elysée jusqu'au 20 21 juillet
c'est qu'il est protégé par le prison la
république la question c'est pourquoi
peut-être que c'est des choses
absolument pas importante mais vu les
révélations que l'on a eu depuis tout ce
que l'on a pu savoir notamment les
financements russe visiblement ce n'est
pas rien ceci n'est pas une affaire
d'état mais ça y ressemble quand même de
plus en plus et je terminerai juste sur
un point avant de de rendre la parole
c'est que il y à des mécanismes
constitutionnels qui permettrait ensuite
d'agir
1 si véritablement on pense que il y à
une affaire d'état qu'il y a des des
éléments qui justifient que on aille
encore plus loin
il ya une procédure qui est prévu par
l'article 68 de la constitution qu est
la destitution du chef de l'état dans le
temps qu'a d'un manquement manifestement
incompatible avec l'exercice de son
mandat
et si je ne dis pas couvert les
financements russe on peut s'interroger
sur ce je pense pas qu'on soit une
situation d'articles récente 8c
supposerait une inconduite personnels
graves du président de la république
on n'en est pas là on n'a pas les
éléments je dirais c'était pas la
mission de la commission d' enquête
je pense qu'à ce stade ce que ça montre
c'est que l'exécutif ne sait pas se
contrôler lui-même et que la haute
administration française ne sait pas se
contrôler elle même
contrairement à ce qu'elle prétend
toujours il a fallu le sénat il a fallu
des des anciens hauts fonctionnaires
c'est comme ça je pense qu autrefois si
je voulais yal'aspect fait divers il
yal'aspect anecdotique les personnalités
les polices parallèles et puis à les
questions institutionnelles et
structurelles ces affaires là ont
toujours existé il ya eu les affaires
pasqua pandraud il ya eu la françafrique
ça a toujours existé sous la vème
république
je pense qu'à un certain stade on
n'avait pas le monde mediapart qui
diffusait jockey qui faisaient ce genre
d' enquête faut bien le dire ça y est il
ya eu un rôle de la presse dans cette
affaire-là remet désormais on sait tous
désormais ya twitter désormais ya des
enregistrements c'est impossible de
cacher les choses
alors viens de voir un les sénateurs
quitte la commission des lois et se
dirige vers cette salle etc et mon sens
et sénateurs de la commission des lois
qui a pendant plus de six mois eut les
prérogatives d'une commission denquête
fabrice arfi
beaucoup de choses ont été dites par un
vote de constitutionnalistes sur
justement les possibilités de cette
crise ans michel qui a peut-être
s'ouvrir avec les révélations du sénat
ce matin oui en fait ce qui est pour un
journaliste qui travaille sur cette
affaire dite bennama kron il ya quelque
chose qui relève parfois du défi
cognitif c'est à dire que plus on
cherche plus on trouve et plus on trouve
moins on comprend et et c'est très
particulier et je vous avoue que ça
parfois je suis assez désarçonné par par
cette affaire tentaculaire cette affaire
mais si vous voulez on est certain
d'avoir les auteurs du crime
mais on n'a pas encore tous les cadavres
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que de
mon point de vue nous ne sommes qu'au
début de la sphère bénin
nous ne sommes qu'au début même si bien
sûr il ya eu les révélations du mais de
du monde puis de mediapart sur les
violences de la contrescarpe et du
jardin des plantes petit ce qui est
caché attachée votre thème traduite avec
esther benbassa sénatrice écologiste
rattaché ici au groupe communiste de
paris
membre de cette commission dans quel
parlementaire peut être un petit mot
avant de rentrer salle clemenceau oui
effectivement esther benbassa pouvez
vous nous dire et bien comment s'est
passée la réunion de la commission ce
matin et quelle était l'ambiance pour ce
rapport que vous avez je le vois dans
les mains oui ça s'est passé très
calmement
voilà il ya beaucoup de choses que nous
savions déjà sur les dysfonctionnements
de l'état concernant benalla l'opacité
etc
mais bon il y aura une saisine plusieurs
saisons voilà ce que je peux vous dire
plusieurs plusieurs saisine de la
justice donc à d'abord baissé ils vont
être présentés au bureau du sénat qui
lui même va demander ensuite au
président le sénateur gérard larcher de
saisir la justice a confirmé nos clients
en tout cas plus qu'une saisine de la
justice a priori et sinon donc il y
avait une ambiance plutôt j'étais pas
révolutionnaire est limité oui avec
quelques abstentions quelques
abstentions élus et sinon des votes pour
ah oui la majorité 1 voilà d'accord et
bien très bien merci beauval à esther
benbassa d'avoir répondu à nos questions
alors que nous attendons les rapporteurs
pour et bien que ce rapport soit
dévoilée à la presse d'un instant à
l'autre delphine merci beaucoup
tam on voit qu on n'en saura pas plus
les sénateurs ont interdiction de parler
avant cette conférence de presse fabrice
arfi
en tous les cas il ya certainement
unanimité sur les conclusions de ce
rapport
c'était une commission denquête transe
bien parti on peut le dire avec tous les
partis politiques du sénat représentés
au sein de la commission des lois
oui voilà la démocratie parfois ça
fonctionne mais heureusement que le
sénat est là quand on voit la trousse y
volontaire de l'assemblée nationale
quand il s'est agi pour elle de mener
une commission denquête donc on ne peut
quand on est citoyen quelles que soient
nos idées politiques nos parcours en au
cheminement est ravi de voir que ce que
l'efs plus journaliste et philosophe
hannah arendt appelé la force
contraignante de la vérité voilà il ya
des faits il ya des faits les sénateurs
sont là pour comme des perles mettre
dans le bon ordre pour refaire le
collier le collier ça s'appelle la
sphère benallal affaire d'état et on va
voir les conclusions
ensuite qu'ils en tirent quelques
ascensions disent qu'il ya des membres
bien des partis présidence 27 kamiz oui
mais c'est ça qui est terrible
oui mais c'est ça que je trouve que
c'est ça qui est terrible de voir que
parfois dans le monde parlementaires
français le monde politique en général
on n'est pas capable de s'extraire de
l'espèce de bandeaux militants qu'on se
met sur les yeux pour ne pas voir les
faits et que par caporalisme on pense
plus à la protection des siens car cas
une idée supérieure du bien comme moi
infinie bas le président de la
commission des lois à présent de cette
commission denquête qui arrivent il
salue les journalistes nombreux ce matin
au sénat qui attendent bien ce rapport
très attendu de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire elle doit donc livrer ses
préconisations sur la sphère benalla
jean philippe derosier 5 il ya quelques
abstentions c'est ce que nous a dit
esther benbassa ne sais pas peut-être
des sénateurs marche peut-être d'autres
sénateurs ça sera aussi important a
scruté analysé
oui parce que c'est rappelons le c'est
une alors une commission d' enquête
classique réunit la pluralité des des
groupes qui composent l'assemblée mais
là on n'est pas dans une commission d'
enquête classique on essaie la
commission des lois du sénat qui a été
dotée des pouvoirs d'enquêté qui elle
aussi réuni la pluralité des groupes y
compris des sénateurs la république en
marche et alors la question sera de
savoir est-ce qu'ils ont voté contre le
rapport est ce qu'ils se sont abstenus
est ce que peut être certains d'entre
eux ont voté pour
ah on sentait que il y avait certains
membres de ce groupe il ya notamment le
sénateur alain richard qui est un ancien
socialiste qui a rejoint le groupe il y
a quelques mois
qui était un petit peu gêné parfois sur
des propos il ne parlait pas trop et
tenez prenez pas véritablement position
parce qu'on sentait une certaine gêne de
sa part de voilà ton sera intéressant de
savoir quelle a été l'attitude de ces de
ces sénateurs la république en marche
sur le rapport de cette commission des
lois denis branger
j'ai l'impression qu'il ne fait pas bon
être sénateur et les roms actuellement
on a vu sur ce même plateau d'assez
grande tension par exemple entre
messieurs kenner et monsieur patriat les
sénateurs à l'air om sont sur la
défensive
actuellement ou au sénat il leur
appartient de défendre une cause qui
n'est pas facile à défendre
je pense qu'un ancien ministre comme
alain richard a de l'expérience s'est
aussi équipé ne peut y avoir d affaire
qui dépasse un parti ou qui dépasse une
majorité se serait peut-être dans
l'intérêt de cette majorité de purger
cette affaire car et sarafina oui c'est
ce que c'est ce que j'ai essayé de dire
à ma manière plus confuse tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que voilà c'est celle à
force je crois politique de chaque homme
et femme politique de pouvoir s'extraire
de la simple condition militante et de
la protection des intérêts de son parti
que de pouvoir dire les faits quand les
faits pose problème y compris à son
parti la et et moi je n'aime pas cette
idée du caporalisme toujours être j'ai
vécu ça dans la sphère cahuzac avec le
l'assemblée des commissions d'enquêté de
l'assemblée nationale il se trouve que
avec edwy plenel nous avions été tous
les deux les premières personnes à être
interrogés dans la commission denquête
et je me souviens de d'avoir en face de
nous physiquement le groupe socialiste
qui n'avait pas assez de miel sous
sarkozy pour dire tout le bien de notre
travail quand nous révélions les
affaires des financements libyens et
d'autres l'afertes un coup la tortue
romaine pour protéger le gouvernement en
place et surtout qui ait pas d'autres
victimes au sein du gouvernement de la
sphère cahuzac en plus de jérôme cahuzac
et puis juste à côté de moi il y avait
le groupe s'était l'ump allait à
l'époque pour qu'ils nous étions un
journaleux méthodes fascistes
sous nicolas sarkozy qui l'a n'avait pas
assez d'éloges pour dire à quel point
notre travail
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que ce
n'est pas rassurant ça ce serait bien de
voir des comme on le voit dans d'autres
démocraties d'ailleurs dans certaines
démocraties anglo saxon et s'extraire de
à condition politique pour dire voilà
les faits sont là et les flip aux
problèmes y compris au parti que je
représente mais ces demandes d'admission
de le dire ce qu'a montré la sphère
kérizac ce que montre la sphère benalla
c'est que les hyper présidence
deviennent des présidences faible se
fragilise au regard même de la
concentration des pouvoirs par le
président de la république et son
irresponsabilité
on le voit à chaque fois la leçon
devrait un jour en être tirées me
semble-t-il des points de vue
institutionnel ya un problème structurel
le président est trop responsable outre
au pire responsables comme on voudra et
autour de lui tout le monde et fragilisé
les ministres le son la haute fonction
publique cette affaire est un n'est pas
une anecdote de ce point de vue là je
suis passé d'une affaire d'été ou une
affaire d'état mais elle n'est pas
anecdotique elle démontre des
dysfonctionnements qui doivent être
réglés un jour ou l'autre et cette
majorité restera fragile à faire des
gilets jaunes et de greffer là-dessus en
plus je pense que maintenant c'est une
maladie à plusieurs symptômes qui
frappent l'exécutif est en fait c'est
des affaires je dirais pas qu'elles sont
reliés mais elles sont l'illustration de
la même difficulté que l'exécutif avec
la réalité avait avec sa propre
responsabilité afin sur et quand on a un
président de la république pardon qui je
pense que ces discours restera son
discours de la maison de l'amérique
latine le 24 juillet deux jours avant la
rencontre secrète de benalla écrase oui
il a dit cette phrase bien sûr qu'ils
viennent me chercher mais pas que ça
c'est un discours dans lequel il a mis
en cause le chef de l'état le premier
magistrat de france le garant des
libertés constitutionnelles il a mis en
cause le travail du parlement de la
justice et de la presse il a dit que la
presse ne cherchez plus la vérité dans
cette affaire
or sans la presse il n'y aurait pas les
vérités que précisément le président de
la république et l'elysée veulent cacher
dans ce dans ce dossier donc là on est
dans une espèce d'inversion de la
réalité qui est très inquiétant que je
trouve venant du chef de l'état on voit
jean fils de rose et un sur ces images
un ton des prêts à tout on attend a
désormais l'entrée en définit balle
président de la commission des lois il
sera accompagné je le disais un des deux
co rapporteur le socialiste jean-pierre
sueur la sénatrice lr muriel jourda qui
vont donc présenter à la presse leurs
travaux après à sept mois d'enquêté
parlementaire et plus de 34 audition
jean philippe derosier sur ces cas de
parjure a priori
donc plusieurs on rappelle en pour le
téléspectateur est bien ce concours
pénalement les personnes justement qui
aurait fait des faux témoignage d'un
faux témoignage devant une commission
denquête c'est comme un faux témoignage
devant la cour d'assises c'est le même
article qui est du code pénal qui
s'applique et c'est passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amendé prête serment devant la
commission denquête donc on est honni de
dire la vérité toute la vérité et rien
que la vérité et dans l'hypothèse d'un
parjure c'est à dire d'un mensonge
effectivement la commission peut décider
de saisir le bureau du sénat lequel
décidera s'il transmet à la justice ou
non alors qu'on voit effectivement sur
ces images l'entrée de philippe bas à
muriel jourda jean pierre sueur la
commission des lois qui étaient réunis
ce matin pour faire adopter son rapport
va donc pouvoir le présenter à la presse
il ya eu 34 éditions vous les avez tout
vécu en direct sur public sénat ces
auditions avec cet effort notamment deux
fois alexandre benallal ancien chargé de
mission de l'elysée qui est venu bien
témoigner sur ses fonctions beaucoup de
révélations beaucoup d'incohérences
d'invraisemblances on va d'ailleurs donc
écouter et bien ce que nous disent ce
matin à les sénateurs après à leurs
travaux et puis on se retrouvera juste
après bien pour analyser leur conclusion
est que tout de suite a fini pas merci
messieurs attendent déjà
[Musique]
le coup
même loup c'est bien vous
ils sont tous à dire leurs astuces et je
les nourris pelli mars un message qui
regardent au poste merci
je demande à la sépare de ses presses
exemple il halète mai
bien
et j'attends la fin de la distribution
du dossier de presse
pour que chacun ait pu rejoindre sa
place
je crois que nous y sommes mesdames et
messieurs je vous remercie tout d'abord
de l'intérêt que vous portez aux travaux
de nos rapporteur il n'y aurait pas eu
d'affaires benalla si une sanction
appropriée avait été prise dès le 2 mai
2018 par le licenciement de l'intéressé
et l'information du procureur de la
république au titre de l'article 40 du
code de procédure pénale le travail qui
s'achève aujourd'hui
dans la présentation du rapport de
muriel jourda et de jean pierre sueur a
duré près de sept mois
plus de 40 personnes ont été
auditionnées sous serment
une trentaine de demandes d'informations
complémentaires ont été faites auprès de
l'elysée et des ministères concernés
après dépouillement des documents qui
nous ont été remis il y en a près de 500
pages et des témoignages recueillis sous
serment
les rapporteurs ont achevé leur tâche
leur rapport est rendu public sur
autorisation de la commission des lois
qui en a délibéré ce matin pendant plus
de trois heures il sera communiquée dans
la journée à monsieur le président de la
république à monsieur le premier
ministre il leur appartiendra d'en tirer
les conséquences qu'ils jugeront utiles
au bon fonctionnement de l'état pour que
les faits constatés ne se reproduise pas
l'objet de notre travail et est triple
tout d'abord remplir la mission
fondamentale du parlement dans
l'exercice de ses pouvoirs de contrôle
s'agissait pour nous de faire oeuvre de
vérité de rendre l'état plus transparent
plus efficace plus respectueux du droit
et permettre aux français de se faire
leur propre jugement
grâce au caractère public de tous nos
travaux et grâce aussi au caractère
public de ce rapport cela doit permettre
de renforcer pour l'avenir la prévention
des abus de pouvoir
nos travaux n'aurait-il eu que ce
résultat pour les centaines de milliers
de françaises et de français qui nous
ont suivis que ce résultat serait déjà
très important pour notre démocratie
les médias eux mêmes ont pu développer
certaines de leurs investigations très
utile en prenant appui sur les
déclarations publiques qui ont été
recueillis au cours de nos auditions
cette mission est essentielle nous
l'avons rempli je crois sereinement mais
sans inhibition en toute indépendance
en prenant le temps qu'il fallait
c'est un rôle que de notre point de vue
le sénat était particulièrement à même
de tenir car c'est une assemblée
parlementaire libre indépendante
non-alignés sa tradition c'est celle du
dialogue et de la recherche du consensus
c'est aussi celle du pluralisme en
témoigne le fait que la majorité
parlementaire du sénat et l'opposition
du sénat se sont réunis pour travailler
ensemble dans le seul souci de faire
émerger la vérité
notre deuxième objectif c'était de
proposer des mesures propres à éviter le
renouvellement des désordres constatés
prévenir et sanctionner les conflits
d'intérêts parmi les collaborateurs des
cabinets pour qu'il ne soit dans la main
de personne
garantir le respect des standards de
sécurité les plus élevées en ce qui
concerne la protection du président de
la république et celle du premier
ministre
mieux encadrer la délivrance
l'utilisation le retrait des passeports
diplomatiques et de service
faire en sorte que les promotions dans
la réserve de la gendarmerie nationale
soit mieux réguler et plus généralement
veiller à ce que les collaborateurs des
autorités politiques n'interfère pas
avec le fonctionnement opérationnel des
administrations ceci est un point
évidemment très important notre dernière
objectif c'est de faire mieux respecter
pour l'avenir les prérogatives du
parlement
quand il agit en vertu des pouvoirs de
contrôle qu'il tient de la constitution
de la déclaration des droits de l'homme
dont l'article gaz dit que la société a
droit de demander compte à tout agent
public de son administration
et ce droit fondamental des citoyens
foot et citoyens français nous
l'exerçons nous la représentation
nationale en leur nom et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous ne pouvons tout
simplement pas laisser sans suites
ce que nous considérons comme avoir été
des faux témoignages
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir parce
qu'il en va de l'autorité dû parlement
pour remplir au nom des français
une prérogative tout à fait essentiel
pour la démocratie
nous avons constamment veillé à la
sérénité de nos travaux et au respect de
notre mandat sans jamais répondre aux
pressions ni alimenter des polémiques
autour des rebondissements à répétition
qui ont accompagné nos travaux et que
nous avons subi sans les avoir
provoquées
nous avons également été attentif à ne
pas livrer de conclusion partielle avant
d'avoir achevé un travail méticuleux d'
analyse et d'en avoir délibéré
il n'y a pas une affaire benalla il y à
une affaire de la contrescarpe et du
jardin des plantes
une affaire du permis de port d'armes
irrégulier une affaire de contrat russe
une affaire de passeport diplomatique
une affaire démission d'un chargé de
mission dans le bon fonctionnement de la
sécurité présidentielle et c'est
principalement cette affaire-là à
laquelle les autres sont d'ailleurs
liées qui depuis le début aura été le
coeur de notre mandat à la différence de
l'assemblée nationale dont l' enquête
visait directement les événements du 1er
mai qui font l'objet d'une enquête
judiciaire
notre mission portait en effet et je
cite textuellement le mandat sur la
participation de personnes étrangères
aux forces de sécurité à des activités
de maintien de l'ordre et à la
protection des hautes personnalités
ainsi que sur les sanctions aux
manquements constatés
nous nous sommes donc essentiellement
penché sur la protection du président de
la cinquième puissance du monde dans une
période de l'histoire où les risques
terrorisc sont particulièrement élevés
notre président est doté de pouvoirs
constitutionnels très important parmi
les chefs d'exécutifs des grandes
démocraties notamment en matière de
défense
il incarne spécifiquement la continuité
de l'état
sa sécurité n'est pas une affaire
personnelle elle regarde tous les
français elle doit être au niveau des
meilleurs standards internationaux et je
pense d'ailleurs qu'elle l'est au moment
où je vous parle nous avons d'ailleurs
inscrit notre travail dans une approche
comparative avec les systèmes étrangers
pour bien les connaître notre mandat
nous l'avons scrupuleusement respectés
comme nous avons respecté aussi la
mission de la justice et les
prérogatives constitutionnelles du
président de la république
cela ne nous empêchait évidemment pas
d'interroger sous serment d'une part
des personnes faisant l'objet d' enquête
judiciaire et d'autre part des
collaborateurs du chef de l'état comme
ce fut à plusieurs reprises le cas dans
le passé pour de grandes commission
denquête de l'assemblée nationale comme
du sénat mais des précautions
particulières s'impose auxquels nous
avons été très attentifs ne pas faire le
travail de la justice ne pas exposer une
personne entendue à s'accuser sous
serment ne pas mettre en cause de
décisions ou d'actes du président de la
république et nous n'avons pas fait mais
ne pas renoncer pour autant à l'exercice
de nos propres prérogatives que nous
tenons de la constitution et que nous
exerçons au nom du peuple français pour
l'évaluation du fonctionnement des
services de la présidence de la
république et des services du
gouvernement mis à la disposition de la
présidence de la république c'est le cas
du groupe de sécurité de la présidence
de la république et du commandement
militaire du palais de l'elysée nous
n'étions pas en charge d'une instruction
judiciaire mais d'une mission de
contrôle parlementaire
nous avons par conséquent enquêter sur
le fonctionnement de l'état est bas sur
les agissements de monsieur benalla
c'est très différent
je peux vous en donner quelques exemples
et nous y reviendrons naturellement tout
à leur place de la contrescarpe ce ne
sont pas les voies de fait que
pourraient caractériser la justice qui
nous intéressait c'était les conditions
dans lesquelles monsieur benalla s'est
trouvée qui venait de décisions
administratives et sait les conséquences
qu'on a tiré de ces voies de fait au
niveau des autorités publiques qui
pouvaient en tirer
s'agissant des passeports diplomatiques
ça n'est pas l'utilisation illicite de
ces passeports qui fait l'objet d'une
instruction judiciaire qui nous
intéressait c'était d'expliquer
et comment il était possible que ces
passeports soit resté entre les mains de
l'intéressé plusieurs mois après qu'il
ait cessé ses fonctions à l'elysée
s'agissant des contrats russe cdpa le
rôle propre de monsieur benalla dans la
conclusion de ces contrats qui nous
intéressait c les raisons pour laquelle
les règles déontologiques qui
s'appliquait à la prévention des
conflits d'intérêts il s'agit d'un
conflit d'intérêt majeur s'il est avéré
n'ont pas été mis en oeuvre ni avant le
licenciement ni après le licenciement de
monsieur bénard et s'agissant de la
sécurité présidentielle
naturellement ce à quoi nous avons été
sensibles ça n'est pas de caractériser
un certain nombre d'attributs de la
fonction comme des avantages des
privilèges ou pour reprendre
l'expression de monsieur benalla des
caprices c'est de savoir si ces
attributs était caractéristique de la
fonctions réellement exercées par
monsieur bénin en matière de sécurité
puisque c'était l'objet même de notre
travail et c'est une question évidemment
essentiel du point de vue de l'état que
la justice n'est pas en mesure de
traiter chacun son rôle
entre nos différentes institutions
hambourg dans strictement notre examen à
des questions relatives au
fonctionnement de l'état nous avons
réuni suffisamment d'éléments pour
estimer que la sécurité du président de
la république a été affectée que de
nombreuses erreurs ou anomalies les
défaillances ont été constatées sanction
insuffisante au départ justice tenue à
l'écart permis de port d'armes
irrégulier port d'une arme par monsieur
b nana en présence du président de la
république non respect des règles de
déontologie sur les conflits d'intérêts
maintien en possession de monsieur
benalla d'un téléphone crypté de
passeport diplomatique ou de service
qu'ils n'ont pas été récupérées absence
d' instructions données à la police de
l'air et des frontières
de ne pas permettre à monsieur benalla
de sortir au moyen de ces passeports
diplomatique ou de service
cela fait tout de même beaucoup si bien
que les faits constatés le premier mais
apparaissent maintenant comme la partie
émergée d'un iceberg
du point de vue du bon fonctionnement de
l'état les informations qui se sont
accumulés ensuite sont sans doute plus
grave encore que les événements survenus
en marge de la fête du travail comme l'
ordonnance de 1958 relative à l'exercice
de ses pouvoirs dans quête par le
parlement le prévoit j'ai donc décidé
conjointement avec les deux rapporteurs
et après avoir consulté ce matin la
commission des lois de demander au
président du sénat que le bureau de
notre assemblée c'est la procédure
délibère en vue de saisir le procureur
de la république de paris
des faux témoignages caractérisée de
monsieur benalla des contradictions
apparues entre les premières
déclarations de collaborateurs immédiats
du président de la république sur le
rôle de monsieur benalla en matière de
sécurité et les éléments et témoignages
recueillis par la suite tout en
soulignant d'ailleurs la qualité et la
précision de nombreuses informations qui
nous ont été apportées par les dix
collaborateurs sur d'autres points très
importants
nous souhaitons aussi que l'ensemble du
rapport soit lui-même transmis au
procureur de la république afin qu'il
puisse apprécier l'existence éventuelle
d'autres faux témoignage susceptible
d'avoir été commis par des personnes
auditionnées
il appartient donc au bureau d'en
décider et les deux rapporteurs se
joignent à moi pour faire cette demande
au bureau
je voudrais vous dire en conclusion que
l'autorité qui peut s'attacher à notre
travail vient essentiellement du respect
par les rapporteurs et par tous les
membres de la commission des lois
au cours des auditions de notre mandat
que j'ai rappelé mais aussi du respect
des prérogatives du président de la
république d'autonomie aucun acte aucune
décision n'a jamais été mise en cause
par la commission des lois et du respect
de l'autorité judiciaire il y à la part
de l'autorité judiciaire
il y à la part de l' enquête
parlementaire elles sont complémentaires
et elles vont dans la même direction
c'est très important de le dire
nous avons confiance dans les
institutions de la république le
parlement auquel nous appartenons bien
sûr la présidence de la république
l'autorité judiciaire le gouvernement et
nous tenons à ce que cette confiance
soit confortée par les propositions que
nous faisons qui sont des propositions
constructives destinées à éviter qu'à
l'avenir on puisse se retrouver dans ce
genre de situation je vais donc
maintenant donner la parole
successivement à madame jourdain est un
monsieur sueur à moi que je la donne à
monsieur sueur et à madame jourdain et
ils vont vous présenter ma tonne
maintenant le contenu même de leur
rapport madame jourdain
merci monsieur présidente de me donner
la parole pour présenter effectivement
d'une façon synthétique mais que nous
pensons néanmoins complète les travaux
que nous avons menées autour de quatre
points que je qualifierais de clés qui
nous sont apparus au fur et à mesure de
nos travaux le premier point est
relative aux sanctions aux sanctions qui
ont pu être prononcée à l'encontre
d'alexandre benalla après le 1er mai
événements qui ont d'abord justifié la
tenue de nos travaux
en réalité plusieurs défaillances ont
été mises à jour dans la réaction des
autorités fonctionnel hiérarchique de
monsieur benalla est également de
vincent
kraz qui participaient aux événements du
1er mai après ces événements je le dis
sans ambages la commission n'a trouvé ni
approprié les premières suites qui ont
été apportées aux agissements commis ni
proportionnée les sanctions qui ont été
prétendument infligées et nous avons
regretté l'incompréhensible indulgence
de la hiérarchie d'alexandre benalla qui
a conservé dans l'équipe de l'elysée un
collaborateur qui avait gravement manqué
à ses devoirs et quand jany qu'il avait
gravement manqué à ses devoirs
ça n'est pas de mon avis c'est de l'avis
de toutes les personnes qui ont été
auditionnées par la commission ce qui
frappe en réalité ça n'est pas tant la
sanction qui a été infligé en mai mais
bien la confiance qui a été maintenue
alexandre benalla jusqu'en juillet tout
d'abord nous avons pu constater ce que
je qualifierais d'une chaîne
d'irresponsabilité en l'absence de
signalement immédiat au parquet de ces
faits
rappelons-nous revêtu d'un signe de
police selon l'igpn est peut-être armée
sur la voie publique pour l'un d'eux
alexandre ménard et vincent kraz ont
ouvertement le 1er mai 2018 fait usage
de la force à l'encontre de manifestants
les suites pénales relève aujourd'hui de
la justice mais ces faits présentait
déjà pour les autorités et
fonctionnaires informer tous les indices
qui permettait d'envisager la commission
d'un délit et il appartenait donc à ses
fonctionnaires informer en toute
hypothèse de soumettre la qualification
de ces faits au parquet en application
de l'article 40 du code de procédure
pénale de façon assez surprenante c'est
la présidence de la république et non
pas le ministère de l'intérieur qui a
été alertée la première dans la nuit du
1er mai de l'existence d'une vidéo
vidéos des incidents et c'est également
la présidence de la république qui a
transmis l'information au ministre de
l'intérieur et au préfet de police
al'inverse plusieurs services plusieurs
services clés dont l'intervention aurait
pu perturber le règlement discret de
cette affaire benalla et bien ont été
maintenus dans l'ignorance jusqu'en
juillet 2018
ni la direction générale de la police
nationale ni l'inspection générale
de la police nationale ni la direction
générale de la gendarmerie nationale
dont été avisés de ces faits aucune des
autorités qu'ils étaient informés
aucune de ces autorités c'est à dire
l'elysée la préfecture de police le
ministère de l'intérieur qui connaissait
ses agissements ne les a signalé au
procureur de paris
chacune se défaussant a posteriori sur
l'autre de la responsabilité du
signalement ce que nous en avons déduit
c'est que bien loin du traitement
hiérarchique normale rapide rigoureux et
qui aurait mérité un événement appliquer
un agent de l'elysée de ce niveau de
surcroît ces dysfonctionnements témoigne
de la fébrilité de l'exécutif face à un
risque politique et risques que
représentait la diffusion de cette vidéo
sur internet et donne le sentiment que
l'elysée a vainement il faut dire
souhaitait se réserver le traitement du
problème pour se préserver d'un possible
scandale
voilà quelles sont les premières
conclusions sur cette chaîne des
responsabilités
s'agissant toujours des suites données
aux événements du 1er mai rencontre
monsieur benalla je dois dire que nous
émettons des doutes assez clair sur
l'effectivité réel des sanctions qui ont
été infligés les informations qui
étaient été recueillies par la
commission sur la portée réelle des
sanctions prononcées à l'encontre
d'alexandre benalla mais également de
vincent kraz ont permis de démentir
plusieurs explications qui avait été
donnée par le porte parole du président
de la république lors d'une conférence
de presse donnée à l'elysée le 19
juillet 2018 et qui avait fortement
exagérée me semble-t-il la réalité de la
sanction prononcée en mai
concernant la mise à pied de quinze
jours qui était annoncé d'alexion de
benalla par l'elysée et vincent crasse
par le parti en marche
les auditions de notre commission ont
révélé qu'elle ne se sont en fait
traduite par aucune conséquence
financière immédiate pour les intéressés
et à ce jour nous n'avons d'ailleurs pas
la certitude que la conséquence
financière était réel concernant la
rétrogradation dont l'action pénale ice
ans s'est alors fait l'objet sa
hiérarchie avait mis en avant le retrait
à titre de sanction des compétences en
matière de déplacements officiels du
président de la république
toutefois il a été confirmé à notre
commission que cette décision était
provisoire et compensé par l'attribution
de nouvelles tâches
et surtout ce principe de rétrogradation
a été assortie d'importantes
exception participation à la
panthéonisation de simone veil le 1er
juillet également cérémonies du
14-juillet fait non négligeable pour les
français au retour de l'équipe de france
de football le 16 juillet et surtout
maintien de l'accompagnement des
déplacements privés du président de la
république sanctions mais surtout
confiance maintenue ainsi que je le
disais en préambule
alexandre bédat à conserver enfin des
moyens qui étaient inchangées ses
passeports ces véhicules voire renforcée
puisque à logements de fonction lui a
été attribué à la mi juin alors qu'il
avait été sanctionné et il continuer de
participer à la réflexion sur la mise en
place de la future direction de la
sécurité du président de la république
la commission estime donc que ces
décisions témoigne d'une volonté - de
sanctionner que de ménager dans
l'immédiat l'exposition médiatique
d'alexandre bennasar un contexte délicat
voilà le premier point clé sur lequel
nous souhaitions faire part de nos
conclusions
monsieur président tueur merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs dans
la continuité de ce que vient de dire
une briel jourda je vais aborder les
questions de sécurité
vous savez ce qui est frappant dans
cette affaire c'est que dès lors qu'il
est apparu que monsieur benalla était
considéré comme disposant de protection
d'une autorité
bien que cela ne fut aucunement
formalisé dès lors que c'était perçu
comme tel
tout s'est mis à 10 fonctionné depuis
l'elysée jusqu'au ministère de
l'intérieur à la préfecture de police au
quai d'orsay et même dans les ambassades
ou sur la question des faux passeports
qu'à évoquer le président il ya eu des
comportements étranges comme si et
peut-être même jusqu'à matignon
voyez vous comme si un seul être par son
autorité supposé faisait
que tout se mettait à dysfonctionner par
cercles successifs alors je vais vous
dire au point de vue de la sécurité que
à l'opposé de la description qui a été
fait par les collaborateurs de la
présidence de la république est à
l'opposé des déclarations faites devant
la commission qui sont entre guillemets
dans le rapport et dans l' annexe à la
lettre que vous avez dans vos dossiers
déclaration faite par monsieur strzoda
par monsieur de lavergne et par monsieur
colère il sait il est apparu que
monsieur alexandre benalla avait exercé
devait une fonction tout à fait
essentiel pour l'organisation et la
gestion de la sécurité du président de
la république
au risque d'en perturber le
fonctionnement normal on a pu obtenir
non sans mal et avec retard cher
président la fiche de poste
la lettre de mission officielle qui
définissait les missions de monsieur
alexandre benalla et lorsqu on la lit et
elle figure en annexe du rapport on
constate que contrairement à ce qui a
été dit sous serment devant la
commission une mission spécifique de
coordination des services de sécurité de
la présidence de la république lui
étaient confiés et qu'il exerçait seul
directement sous l'autorité du directeur
de cabinet
plusieurs éléments tendent à confirmer
que contrairement aux affirmations des
proches du chef de l'état cette mission
ne recouvrait pas uniquement et loin
s'en faut
des considérations à caractère
logistique à la lumière des témoignages
recueillis il apparaît qu alexandre
benalla fort de la confiance et de la
liberté d'actions qui lui étaient
accordées et dans l'ambivalence des
missions officielles qui lui étaient
confiées s'était arrogé un rôle central
dans le fonctionnement des services de
sécurité de ce qui est comme l'a rappelé
notre président la cinquième puissance
du monde
il est en particulier établi qu'il se
serait à plusieurs reprises immiscé dans
certaines décisions relevant la gestion
de la gestion du dispositif de la
sécurité du président de la république
ainsi en at il été de la mise en oeuvre
d'une cellule de réservistes de la
gendarmerie nationale au sein du
commandement militaire du palais de
l'elysée ou du recrutement de plusieurs
agents parmi lesquels monsieur vincent
kraz il est également hautement probable
qu alexandre benalla à dans les fait
participer activement aux dispositifs de
sécurité des déplacements du chef de
l'état prenant un ascendant sur les
responsables opérationnels de la
sécurité s'imposant comme un
interlocuteur privilégié des autorités
de sécurité publique la commission
également réuni des éléments concordants
donnant à penser qu alexandre benalla
exercer dans les faits une mission et
une fonction de protection rapprochée du
président de la république ce qui a été
pourtant obstinément nier par les
principaux responsables de l'elysée que
nous avons reçues
en atteste tout d'abord son
positionnement permanent à proximité
immédiate du chef de l'état lors de
déplacements auxquels ils participaient
qui de l'avis d'experts correspondrait à
une position des pôles jeu citant dream
est chargé d'évacuer le président de la
république d'en décider si dans des
situations extrêmes justifié par le
besoin de passer des messages au chef de
l'état un tel positionnement paraît
pourtant n'avoir jamais été adopté par
aucun des prédécesseurs ni aucun des
collègues d'alexandre benalla surtout le
permis de port d'armes et j'insiste
là-dessus qui lui a été attribué en
octobre 2017 par la préfecture de police
dans des conditions inédites et
dérogatoire au droit commun
à tel point que l'intéressé lui même
avait envisagé à défaut un décret secret
du président de la république pour
l'autoriser à porter une arme et nous en
fournit sont la preuve
cela ne pouvait se justifier par
d'autres raisons qu'une fonction de
protection rapprochée
le soutien appuyé de sa hiérarchie à la
demande qu'il avait formulées de même
que les contradictions devant la
commission des collaborateurs du
président de la république pour
justifier ce permis de port d'armes
accréditent l'idée qu'alexandre benalla
exercé des missions de protection
rapprochée requérant contrairement à ses
collègues le port d'une arme
il a par ailleurs reconnu avoir porté
cette arme en présence du président de
la république ce qui est sans précédent
par rapport à un certain nombre de
situations identiques par le passé
qu'elle résulte d'une volonté expresse
de la hiérarchie ou d'une vision
extensive par l'intéressé des missions
qu'ils y étaient confiées il ne fait nul
doute que l'intérêt que la présence et
l'interférence d'un individu
relativement peu expérimentés et
soucieux d'affirmer son autorité dans un
milieu de professionnels aguerris
sélectionnés et formés et pu constituer
une source de dysfonctionnements et un
facteur de fragilisation du dispositif
de sécurité du président de la
république la liberté les pouvoirs
excessifs
l'essai
un chargé de mission dans un domaine
aussi sensible que la sécurité du chef
de l'état témoigne aux yeux de notre
commission de l'imprudence de la
présidence de la république dans
l'encadrement d'un individu qui avait
pourtant fait preuve par le passé de
comportement professionnel inapproprié
vous lirez le rapport la commission a
ainsi découvert qu alexandre benalla
avait été licencié de son poste de
chauffeur personnel de monsieur arnaud
montebourg alors ministre du
redressement productif en raison de son
manque de jeu site discrétion
responsabilité et transparence notamment
parce qu'il s'était prévalu du soutien
du ministre pour une demande déjà de
permis de port d'armes j'ajoute pour
finir qu'il est apparu que monsieur
benalla a participé une cellule très
restreinte associant le chef du gspr le
commandant militaire et que cette
cellule était chargé de définir une
nouvelle stratégie pour la sécurité de
la présidence de la république et du
président de la république et que
l'objectif était pour monsieur benalla
comme il l'a déclaré publiquement et
entre guillemets c'était dans le journal
du dimanche d'établir un système qui
prendrait des distances à l'égard du
ministère de l'intérieur
perçue par lui comme faisant obstacle à
cette perspective qui était sans doute
d'autonomiser quelque peu le dispositif
de sécurité du président de la
république
contrairement à la tradition qui existe
depuis le début de la vème république
pour le dispositif de sécurité du
président de la république est
exclusivement constituée de policiers et
de gendarmes relevant hier du ministère
de la défense du ministère de
l'intérieur aujourd'hui pour l'essentiel
du ministère
de l'intérieur si sa collègue madame
jourdain
merci monsieur le président la troisième
série de dysfonctionnements que nous
avons mises à jour l'existence de graves
défaillances des autorités compétentes
pour s'assurer du retrait effectif des
prérogatives d'alexandre benalla après
son licenciement à effet du 1er août
donc nous avons été alertés fin décembre
par plusieurs articles de presse et dès
janvier nous avons mené une nouvelle
audition une nouvelle investigation et
nous avons eu alors la confirmation que
les diligences minimales nécessaires
pour garantir la pleine application de
l'ascension licenciement d'alexandre
benalla n'avait pas été accompli par la
présidence de la république et les
ministères concernés notamment pour
s'assurer de la restitution après son
départ des moyens dont ils disposaient
uniquement pour l'exercice de ses
fonctions
le premier moyen dont il s'agit et le
téléphone théorème dans lequel on a pu
noter pour lequel on a pu noter un
manque de diligence regrettable des
services alors même qu'il s'agissait
d'un moyen de communication hautement
sécurisé qui a été présenté comme
nécessaire à l'exercice des missions de
la chefferie de cabinet encore que nous
avons pu nous convaincre de ce que
personne avant ni après monsieur b
d'alan a estimé nécessaire à ses
fonctions ce téléphone théorème pour
autant c'est un moyen hautement
sécurisés et la présidence de la
république ne s'est pas aperçue au
moment de l'inventaire du bureau de
monsieur b dallas qui a eu lieu le 2
août de la non restitution de ce
terminal théorème la présidence un
public ne va s'en apercevoir qu en
octobre 2018
à l'occasion du recensement de
l'intégralité des appareils qui sont mis
à disposition
c'est à dire plusieurs mois après la
date effective du licenciement
en outre après qu en octobre 2018 la
disparition a été découverte
l'elysée ne s'est pas assuré que
l'appareil était restitué et l'elysée
c'est uniquement assuré qu'il avait été
désactivé à distance et qu'il n'a pas
été utilisé aucune demande de
restitution de l'équipement n'a été
adressée à l'ancien chargé de mission et
ça n'est qu'en janvier 2019 que ce
terminal a été rendue sur proposition
d'ailleurs du conseil d'alexandre bénin
le deuxième série de dysfonctionnements
s'agissant des restitutions de
restitution des moyens mis à disposition
de monsieur benalla est relative à ces
passeports lorsqu'il était en fonction à
l'elysée alexandre bédat la disposait de
pas moins de quatre passeports
professionnels de passeports
diplomatiques et deux passeports de
service
aucun n'a été restituée lors de son
licenciement
ces passeports diplomatiques ont été en
revanche utilisé à une vingtaine de
reprises 23 selon l'intéressé lui-même
entre le 1er août et le 31 décembre 2018
pour seront notamment au tchad en israël
et est probablement au maroc et aux
bahamas
ces passeports ont d'abord été attribuée
dans des conditions qui étaient
anormales l'attribution simultanée de
quatre passeports professionnels ne
semble ni courante ni justifiées à ce
niveau de responsabilité est d'ailleurs
l'intéressé n'a pas été capable de s'en
expliquer
se contentant de se retrancher derrière
la responsabilité des ministères qui
avait accepté lui délivrer ses titres
successifs
le motif de délivrance du premier
passeport de service nous l'avons
découvert au cours de nos investigations
est un passeport qui a été délivré
lorsque monsieur v dallas était en
détachement comme chef de cabinet à la
délégation interministérielle pour
l'égalité des chances des français
d'outre-mer en 2016 et ce premier motif
ne manque pas de surprendre puisque ce
document était réclamée en vue d'un seul
déplacement pour répondre à l'invitation
du président de l'office européen des
brevets qui est l organe d'emploi
d'élection de benalla et surtout pour se
rendre en allemagne alors même qu'un
passeport n'est pas utile pour se rendre
en allemagne mais il a été délivré pour
ce motif
le renouvellement du premier passeport
diplomatique a eu lieu le 24 mai 2010
8 alors même que monsieur benalla
revenez suite à sa suspension
disciplinaire et alors qu'il n'aurait
normalement dû conserver aucun rôle en
matière de déplacements internationaux
et en outre selon l'elysée cette demande
aurait été faite par monsieur benalla
lui même sans passer par le service du
protocole ni l'échelon hiérarchique
supérieur
enfin s'agissant du mode de délivrance
de ces passeports concernant
l'utilisation allégués d'un faux
documents pour l'obtention du second
passeport de service
il appartient à la justice de se
prononcer sur responsabilité pénale
d'alexandre benalla puisque il nous a
fait était indiqué que ce passeport
avait été fourni alors même que la
demande avait été faite par monsieur
benalla lui-même rejeté pour ce motif
est à nouveau reformuler sur la base
d'un document qui n'aurait en réalité
pas émaner de sa hiérarchie
ce que nous pouvons regretter la justice
étant saisi ce que nous pouvons
regretter toutefois s'est vivement
c'est que ces faits qui sont connues
depuis l'automne 2010 8 par l'elysée et
bien n'ont été signalés aux parquets
qu'en janvier 2019 et on peut le dire
sous la pression médiatique puisque en
réalité ils ont été signalés le matin
même de l'audition du directeur de
cabinet du président par notre
commission
suite à ces conditions d'attribution
quelque peu étrange
nous avons constaté également une
restitution tardive
faute de démarches efficaces en réalité
de ces passeports le succès mais n'a été
licencié pour faute à compter du 1er
août 2010 8 pendant plus de cinq mois
les différentes administrations ont été
incapables d'obtenir de lui la
restitution effective et définitive de
ces titres de voyage la restitution a
été effective en janvier 2019 sauf pour
un des passeports de service qui a été
déclaré perdu par monsieur alexandre
bédat les démarches accomplies par les
différentes administrations se sont
limités
d'abord à des lettres de relance qui
n'ont pas été suivies d'effet et en
réalité seuls les révélations dans la
presse ont conduit l'administration
envisager bien sûr bien plus tardivement
des poursuites pénales
enfin plutôt ensuite nous avons pu
constater une invalidation assez
laborieuse des passeports diplomatiques
car des délais très importants se sont
écoulées avant que l'exigence efficaces
soient effectués pour en paix
chez l'utilisation des passeports
diplomatiques nous a été indiqué que
deux éléments s'opposait à la validation
de ces passeports d'abord l'absence
d'une décision de justice qui aurait été
nécessaire et ensuite l'absence d'un
losc d'un logiciel adéquat pour
permettre de faire entrer dans ce
logiciel le motif d'invalidation propre
la situation de monsieur benalla cette
demande
en réalité elle a été faite en novembre
je rappelle que le licenciement et à
effet du 1er juillet 2018
cette demande d'invalidation concernant
les références des passeports
diplomatiques direction de béjaïa a été
transmise par le quai d'orsay au
ministère de l'intérieur en novembre
pour se voir opposer le 26 décembre 2018
les impossibilités techniques et les
problèmes informatiques que je vous ai
signalé
pourtant après que la presse a dévoilé
le 27 10 décembre qu'alexandre pénale
avait pu conserver et utiliser jusqu'à
ce jour les passeports diplomatiques
ces difficultés ont été rapidement et
opportunément levé et la validation a eu
lieu ceci étant indépendamment des
difficultés de techniques de logiciels
qui nous ont été signalés il est assez
surprenant qu'aucune instruction
individuelle n'était donnée à la police
de l'air et des frontières par le
ministère de l'intérieur pour empêcher
l'utilisation d'un tel titre de voyage
lors de la sortie du territoire national
par monsieur benalla ce manque initial
de réactivité des services puis leurs
problèmes de coordination a ainsi permis
alexandre benhaddad continue à utiliser
ces titres de voyage à 23 reprises entre
le 1er août et le 31 décembre pour
sortir du territoire national monsieur
le président en sueur merci dans la
continuité toujours de ce que vient de
d'exprimer muriel jourda
je vais vous dire quelques mots sur les
contrats russe
car en effet cette affaire est une
affaire gigogne et il est heureux voyez
vous je me permets cette incidence que
le sénat existe car nos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale ayant créé une
commission d' enquête qui a explosé en
vol
comme les décisions qu'ils eussent tt
opportune ainsi que l'a dit notre
président philippe bas n'ont pas été
prises le 2 mai ni d'ailleurs le 3 mai
il est d'ailleurs jusqu'à la parution
d'un article dans le journal le monde
eh bien il est heureux que des
parlementaires aient pu enquêter faire
leur travail ce que nous faisons sur
tous les sujets sans aucune restriction
dès lors que nous étions dans le cadre
de notre mission et c'est très important
parce que ce qui apparaît maintenant on
pourrait nous dire que ce n'est pas
essentiellement dans le cadre de notre
mission
mais dès lors qu'il s'agit de
financement de contrats qui ont été
conclues pendant que monsieur benalla et
monsieur kraz était à l'elysée où
étaient en lien avec l'elysée
il y à là quelque chose qui est
considérable pour les conséquences
éventuelles par rapport à la sécurité
non seulement de la présidence de la
république ce qui n'est pas rien vous en
conviendrez
mais au delà
mise en avant dès le début des travaux
de notre commission le manque de
précautions et de diligence de la
présidence de la république dans la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts de
certains de ses collaborateurs pendant
ou après l'exercice de leurs fonctions
s'est confirmée au fil des révélations
sur l' affaire dite des contrats russe
la commission n'a pas pu procéder sur ce
sujet à des demandes d'informations
complémentaires dans les délais impartis
à l'exercice des pouvoirs
d'investigation qui lui ont été
consentis par le sénat pour six mois le
23 juillet 2018
elle tire néanmoins des informations
qu'elle a réuni trois conclusions
majeures d'abord en matière de faux
témoignages les informations révélées
par la presse en particulier les
enregistrements qui ont donné lieu à
diverses péripéties parues dans la
presse également les enregistrements
donc publié par le journal mediapart le
31 juillet janvier 2019 et les
déclarations publiques faites par
monsieur jean maurice bernard président
d'une société qui dans le contexte où
nous sommes s'appelle bizarrement
velours peu lourd le 11 février sur bfm
tv laisse à penser qu alexandre benalla
et vincent kraz se sont rendus coupables
lors de leur audition devant la
commission des lois du sénat le 21
janvier de faux témoignages premièrement
eux sur les trois points suivants
premièrement l'implication d'alexandre
benalla dans la négociation et la
conclusion du contrat liant la société
mars
pas le velours mars à et un représentant
de l'oligarque russe monsieur iskander
makhmoudov profondément lié à monsieur
poutine d'ailleurs comme l'a dit je
crois que c'est notre président ce matin
il y à peu d'oligarques russes qui ne
soit pas lié
monsieur poutine deuxième point
l'engagement des négociations en vue de
la conclusion de ce contrat dès le mois
de mars 2018 j'attire l'attention
mesdames et messieurs sur cette date
dès le mois de mars 2018 alors que
alexandre benalla et vincent grass était
encore en fonctions à l'elysée
troisièmement l'implication de vincent
crabbe dans la reprise du contrat à
compter d'octobre ou 2018 par une
nouvelle société dont il nous a dit
qu'ils s'appellent joue quoi france
clause protection en france en français
dans le texte
d'autres monsieur crasse nous a dit que
c'était par une coïncidence qu'elle
avait été créé le jour où l'autre avait
été fermée justement à la même adresse
ce que nous avons écouté avec attention
comme toujours
deuxième point un g10 trois conclusions
majeures ça c'est la première conclusion
deuxième conclusion les révélations sur
la sphère des contrats russe tendent à
établir l'existence de conflits
d'intérêts majeurs
l'implication de monsieur alexandre
benallal monsieur vincent grass dans la
négociation et la conclusion d'activités
de nature privée qui plus est pour le
compte de sociétés appartenant à des
intérêts étrangers puissant donc adjoint
au chef de cabinet qui négocie avec une
société d intérêts financiers liés
directement à un état étranger est au
plus haut niveau de cet état étranger
constituerait non seulement une faute
déontologique majeur pour les intéressés
mais également un risque pour la
présidence de la république et pour
notre république il ne fait en effet nul
doute que les relations indirectes
entretenu avec un oligarque russe par un
proche collaborateur du chef de l'état
directement impliqués on l'a vu dans la
sécurité de la présidence de la
république et d'un réserviste du
commandement militaire du palais de
l'élysée exercer une responsabilité
d'encadrement seraient de nature en
raison de dépendance de la dépendance
financière qu'elle implique a affecté la
sécurité du chef de l'état et les
intérêts de notre pays
les ramifications de cette affaire des
contrats russe jusqu'à matignon et au
sein de l'armée française se précise à
travers un autre de ses protagonistes
monsieur choukri va crime présentait
comme le compagnon de la responsable du
groupe de sécurité du premier ministre
madame marie elodie poitou qui a depuis
lors démissionnait de ses fonctions et
par ailleurs sous-officier monsieur
wakrim je précise sous-officier affecté
au commandement des opérations spéciales
donc dans un cercle très circonstancié
du renseignement ne manque pas
d'inquiéter quant aux risques de
vulnérabilité que ses activités
commerciales ont fait courir aux plus
hautes institutions de l'état
la deuxième conclusion voici la
troisième alors que la sphère des
contrats russe met en lumière
d'importants dysfonctionnements au plus
haut niveau de l'état
il est certain que la présidence de la
république a péché par manque de
précaution en ne prenant pas toutes les
mesures qui paraissent absolument
nécessaire pour s'assurer que les
intérêts privés de certains de ses
collaborateurs n'interférerait pas avec
l'exercice de leurs fonctions et ne
commettrai pas l'or ne compromettrait
pas excusez moi leur indépendance dès le
début de ses travaux la commission en
effet mis en avant le fait qu'alexandre
benalla comme d'ailleurs cet autre agent
nommé en qualité de chargé de mission à
l'elysée échapper à toute transparence
alors même qu'ils exerçaient des
missions importantes ainsi qu'une
influence certaine sur la réflexion et
les décisions du chef de l'état s'est
chargé de mission employés au sein du
cabinet de la présidence de république
n'ont pas rempli n'ont pas déposé de
déclaration d'intérêt ni de déclaration
patrimoniale au mépris de l'article 11
de la loi du 11 octobre 2013 relative à
la transparence de la vie publique qui
s'applique évidemment à l'ensemble des
collaborateurs du président de la
république au sein du cabinet en tout
cas l'affairé dite des contrats russe
attestent des conséquences d'une telle
négligence
le fait qu'il n'ait été demandé à
alexandre benalla de respecter ses
obligations de déclaration qu'il n'ait
pas été demandée alexandre benalla de
respecter ses obligations de déclaration
a privé l'elysée de la possibilité de
bénéficier des prérogatives de la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique afin d'enquêter sur
d'éventuelles con
li d'intérêt et permettre en cas de
déclaration mensongère ou de
déclarations incomplètes sur des
intérêts privés et sur des intérêts
privés produisant des contrats dont les
sommes sont parus des montants sont
parus dans la presse et chacun a vu que
c'était loin d'être négligeable donc la
haute autorité n'a pas pu enquêter ni
même statuer sur ces questions voilà
pour la question des contrats russe
merci cher monsieur le rapporteur
madame jourdain pas vous présenter je
crois la liste des principaux
dysfonctionnements dont nous avons fait
l'inventaire
merci monsieur le président à titre
liminaire avant de présenter cette liste
je voudrais indiquer qu à ce stade je
pense que vous avez saisies comment la
commission a travaillé et l'évolution de
notre travail nous avons été saisis
initialement du fonctionnement l'état
sur les faits qui se sont déroulés le
1er mai à la contrer ce cas ces faits
concernaient monsieur kraz mais surtout
monsieur benalla c'est sans doute celui
sur lequel nous sommes nous sommes le
plus attardés parce que les faits qui
ont succédé ont plus concerné monsieur
penner et monsieur benalla nous a été
présenté au début des auditions comme
plutôt un bon élément à l'elysée puis à
la fin des auditions comme un individu
pour reprendre le terme qui a été
employé un peu moins recommandables mais
s'il ya une chose qu'il n'a pas varié
dans la façon dont les choses nous ont
été présentés c'est le fait qu'il
s'agissait d'un individu qui avait des
agissements qui étaient isolés et qui ne
pouvait pas être mis en lien avec sa
fonction à l'elysée or au fur et à
mesure de nos auditions au fur à mesure
de la réception des documents que nous
avons demandé des réponses aux questions
nous avons formulé au fur et à mesure
aussi des éléments que nous avons pu
trouver dans la presse et dans les
médias de manière générale eh bien nous
avons découvert qu'en réalité si ces
éléments si ces agissements étaient ceux
d'un homme
il n'avait été possible que parce qu'ils
évoluent est dans un système
qu'ils avaient du fait de ces
dysfonctionnements rendu possible toutes
les anomalies que nous avons pu trouver
et la thèse de la faute de l'homme isolé
s'est effacé au profit du
dysfonctionnement d'une institution qui
a rendu possibles ces multiples
situations normales allant jusqu'à
affecté je crois que jean pierre sur
l'a10 très bien la sécurité du président
de la république alors ses principaux
dysfonctionnements que nous avons
constaté ils sont les quel est son
apport majeur nous semble-t-il ces
dysfonctionnements au sein des services
de l'état et ils ont pu affecter non
seulement la sécurité du président de la
république mais également les intérêts
de notre pays il s'agit d'abord des
pouvoirs excessifs qui ont été laissés à
un collaborateur inexpérimentés dans un
domaine la sécurité du chef de l'état
pourtant essentiel à la continuité de
l'état et je me référais au
développement fait sur ce point par le
président bah nous avons découvert aussi
la nomination atypiques comme lieutenant
colonel de réserve opérationnelle de la
gendarmerie nationale qui a été celle de
monsieur biya nous ne l'avons pas
reprises mais cela est resté présent à
l'esprit de tous
nous avons également mis à jour cette
confiance maintenue et cette
collaboration poursuivi après les graves
dérapages commis par ce collaborateur le
1er mai 2010huit également une remontée
d'informations défaillante au sein de
l'institution policière et de l'exécutif
sur les faits du 1er mai une
dissimulation des faits à la justice du
fait de l'absence de saisine du
procureur de la république au titre de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
une première sanction discrète je vais
indiquer et dont la portée réelle n'est
pas établi un sérieux manque de
précautions dans la prévention des
conflits d'intérêts de certains
collaborateurs du président de la
république un manque de diligence dans
le suivi le retrait des moyens alloués
alexandre dellal après son licenciement
passeport téléphone jeudi revient pas
une réaction plus tardive pour s'assurer
du respect par l'intéressé de ses
obligations déontologiques à l'issue du
contre 1 et enfin un contrôle
insuffisant des affectations des
réservistes au sein du dispositif de
sécurité de l'elysée il s'agit là bien
sûr de monsieur crasse voilà quels sont
ces dysfonctionnements le sud présidente
qui ont été relevés est-ce que vous
pouvez aborder maintenant
les propositions je crois que vous
répartissez oui leur énoncé ses
présidents sueur bercy monsieur le
président donc nous allons faire 13
propositions
alors bien entendu dans le respect de
leur respect je vais présenter six
propositions et muriel jourda on
présentera sept
ça va alors première proposition
on développera si vous avez des
questions pour le moment on va les
énoncés première proposition réformer le
cadre réglementaire relatif au groupe de
sécurité de la présidence de la
république gspr afin d'une part de
réaffirmer la compétence exclusive des
membres des forces de sécurité
intérieure pour assurer la sécurité du
chef de l'état d'autre part formaliser
les règles et procédures de recrutement
au sein de ce gspr proposition numéro 2
maintenir la responsabilité organique du
ministère de l'intérieur sur le groupe
de sécurité de la présidence de la
république
ce qui nous paraît absolument essentiel
sur le plan des institutions
républicaines
ç'a toujours été comme ça depuis le
début de la vème république
je le rappelle t-on maintenir la
responsabilité organique du ministère de
l'intérieur sur le groupe de sécurité de
la présidence de la république et
prévoir la vie du chef du service de la
protection sur la composition de ce
groupe proposition numéro 3 rappelé par
voie de circulaire les règles
déontologiques devant régir les
relations entre les collaborateurs de la
présidence de la république ceux des
cabinets ministériels et les
administrations centrales proposition
numéro 4 mettre fin à l'expérience des
collaborateur officieux du président de
la république et faire respecter
strictement leurs obligations
déclaratives
à tous les chargés de mission de
l'elysée proposition numéro 5
conditionner le recrutement des
collaborateurs du président de la
république à la réalisation d'une
enquête administrative préalable afin de
s'assurer de la compatibilité de leur
comportement avec les fonctions ou des
missions susceptibles de leur être
confiées proposition numéro 6
prévoir par la loi des sanctions pénales
en cas de manquement aux obligations de
déclaration d'une nouvelle activité à la
commission de déontologie de la fonction
publique
ce qui n'a pas été fait dans le cas de
monsieur benalla ni avant ni bien sûr
après
maintenant je suis terminée pour les six
propositions et le jardin ainsi un seul
président la proposition numéro 7 a
trait directement à notre saisine qui
avait mis en avant un dysfonctionnement
l'état qui consistait pour un
collaborateur de l'elysée à intervenir
dans une mission de maintien de l'ordre
qui relèvent elles de l'action du
gouvernement si l'exécutif est constitué
de deux pôles le président la république
et le gouvernement
ils ne doivent pas interférer dans
l'action l'un de l'autre de sorte que
notre proposition numéro 7 est de mettre
fin à la pratique des conseillers
communs aux présidents de la république
et au premier ministre pour respecter la
distinction constitutionnel des
fonctions présidentielles et
gouvernementales seul le gouvernement
étant responsable devant le parlement la
proposition numéro numéro 8 dans le
cadre d'une plus grande transparence et
d'enrichir leurs rapports déposés
annuellement lors de l'examen du projet
de loi de finances les connaisseurs
seront ce que c'est que la nex
budgétaire jaune ce rapport étant
consacré aux personnels affectés dans
les cabinets ministériels l'enrichir
d'un volet supplémentaire permettant de
dresser un tableau du nombre des
missions et des rémunérations des
personnels affectés à la présidence de
la république
la proposition numéro 9 consiste à
renforcer la transparence des
recrutements dans les différentes
réserves de la gendarmerie nationale et
la rigueur des règles de sélection dans
la composante spécialiste de sa réserve
opérationnelle
avec un référentiel de compétences
techniques ou théoriques rechercher un
niveau élevé de formation ou
d'expérience professionnelle nécessaire
pour postuler vérification une
appréciation préalable par un jury pour
préparer et appuyer la décision du
directeur général
la proposition numéro 10 consiste à
rendre obligatoire l'établissement d'une
liste des activités professionnelles
exercées par les réservistes du
commandement militaire du palais de
l'elysée les deux autres propositions 11
et 12 août 12 ont trait au renforcement
des pouvoirs du contrôle du parlement la
proposition numéro 11 consiste à
conforter le pouvoir de contrôle du
parlement sur les services sur les
services de la présidence de la
république non passion de président de
la république mais bien sûr les services
de la présidence de la république
la proposition numéro 12 consiste à
établir et confirmé la plénitude des
pouvoirs d'investigation des commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires dans le respect
du principe de la séparation des
pouvoirs du secret de l'instruction
y compris quand la justice enquête de
son côté sur des crimes et délits à
propos des mêmes fait en exerçant le
contrôle parlementaire sous l'angle
exclusif du fonctionnement de l'état
je peux peut-être illustré monsieur le
président cette proposition car il y à
une nombreux débats sur le fait que
notre commission puisse enquêter alors
que la justice était saisie sur des
faits qui était proche dont on pouvait
penser qu'hésiter similaires et nous
avons toujours défendu le fait que la
justice et le parlement bénéficier de
pouvoirs qui étaient concurrents et de
même valeur constitutionnelle mais ne
s'exerçait pas sur les mêmes éléments ce
qui est expliqué très bien par le
président m'a tout à l'heure puisque
nous nous exerçons le contrôle du
fonctionnement de l'état et nous pouvons
dire qu'à l'occasion de notre mission
nous avons été suivis par la justice car
nous avions demandé au ministère de
l'intérieur un dossier qui avait été
saisi et mis sous scellés
le ministère de l'intérieur nous l'a
refusée pour ce motif
nous sommes donc adressé au juge
d'instruction qui détenait ce dossier eh
bien il a tout simplement lever les
scellés est rendu ce dossier au
ministère pour que nous puissions lui
refaire cette demande le juge a donc
estimé que nous pouvions obtenir cet
élément quand bien même une enquête
judiciaire était en cours mais il est
important
par cette proposition de clarifier ces
éléments
et enfin la proposition numéro 13
consiste à mieux définir la portée
juridique d obligation de signalement au
parquet découlant de l'article 40 du
code de procédure pénale et d'en
informer largement l'ensemble des élus
responsables et agents publics voilà
monsieur le président merci chers
collègues
j'espère que les travaux de nos
rapporteur de la commission des lois
seront utiles qui seront utiles aux
français bien sûr puisque notre travail
s'est fait en toute transparence sous
leur regard et en leur nom mais aussi
utile à l'exécutif par les
recommandations qui viennent de vous est
présentée et dont j'espère que elles
apparaîtront pour ce qu'elles sont c'est
à dire des recommandations constructives
dont une partie d'ailleurs vise
simplement à ce que les règles soient
respectées
je voudrais revenir un instant sur la
lettre que nous avons écrite au
président du sénat pour que le bureau du
sénat soit saisi pour indiquer la
motivation fondamentale qui a été la
mienne et celle des deux rapporteurs
il s'agit pour nous en pensant au
respect des prérogatives nécessaires du
parlement pour eux l'avenir de poser une
exigence exigences de dire la vérité au
parlement et cette exigence qui existe
dans l' ordonnance de 1958 ne doit pas
rester lettre morte car sinon c'est un
droit essentiel que nous exerçons au nom
du peuple français qui seraient bafoués
et c'est la seule raison pour laquelle
nous avons souhaité que le bureau
délibère de la possibilité de saisir le
procureur de la république c'est le
président sur vous voulez ajouter
quelque chose
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
voulais ajouter deux choses premièrement
nous avons tenu muriel jourda et moi
même a co signé cette lettre avec
l'accord bien entendu du président
philippe bas pourquoi pour montrer notre
totale unité bien que chacun sache que
nous n'appartenons pas à des groupes
différents
nous appartenons à des groupes
différents tu vois c'est un lapsus
nous appartenons donc à des groupes
différents et je voulais dire que dans
cette affaire finalement nous n'avions
que un objectif connaître la vérité dire
la vérité
connaître les dysfonctionnements les
mettre à jour le plus possible et tirer
les conséquences prévues par l'
ordonnance et ce qui est important c'est
la lettre que vous avez dans votre
dossier
mais j'insiste c'est aussi la nex la
lettre
carl alex à la lettre comprend toute une
série de citations en treillis mais qui
ont été faites sous serment devant la
commission et qui justifient les
préconisations qu'il y a dans la lettre
par rapport auquel nous prenons
naturellement nos responsabilités devant
le président du sénat le bureau du sénat
et bien sûr devant le parquet la justice
si ce que nous espérons nous sommes
suivis par nos collègues
ça c'est la première marque seconde
remarque cette lettre elle a été écrite
avec beaucoup de soin et nous avons
peser chaque mot
il y a trois points différents
comme l'a dit des chars monsieur bah il
ya trois points différents
premièrement s'agissant de monsieur
benalla et de monsieur kraz au vu des
travaux de la commission des
informations collègues collecter et
aider au vu des travaux de la commission
des informations collectées et de
plusieurs déclarations sous serment de
monsieur alexandre benalla et vincent
kraz dont le détail figure en annexe du
présent courrier nous sommes conduits à
considérer que celles ci constituent des
faux témoignages
premier point deuxième point s'agissant
des trois personnes déjà cité de
l'elysée monsieur strzoda monsieur
colère et monsieur lavergne il est fait
état d informations qu'ils sont
apportées et il est dit que notre
enquête a mis à jour dans leurs
déclarations un certain nombre
d'omissions d'incohérences et de
contradictions
pour le relever figure en annexe et nous
disons que qu'ils ont retenues je prends
les termes exacts
une part significative de la vérité à la
commission lors de leurs auditions
notamment sur le périmètre de la mission
de sécurité exercées par monsieur
benalla dès lors nous demandons au
bureau au présent au bureau du sénat de
faire part de ces éléments et enfin
troisièmement et je me permets
d'insister là dessus
notre lettre comprend cet élément nous
saisissons le parquet de vous proposons
de saisir le parquet afin qu'ils
apprécient s'il ya lieu de procéder à
des investigations concernant d'autres
personnes et d'autres fins que celles et
ceux que nous venons d'expliquer
d'évoquer explicitement
nous n'avons pas mis cette phrase de
manière comme une clause de style il y à
toute une série d'éléments dans le
dossier dans dans le dans le rapport est
aussi dans le document annexé à la
lettre qui peuvent conduire une série
d'investigations
vous comprendrez bien que lorsqu'il ya
des contradictions
on ne sait pas toujours qui a tort et
qui a raison puisqu'ils la contradiction
entre des déclarations
donc il y a trois points différents qui
sont marqués de manière différente
c'est important de le dire le premier
pour deux personnes le second qui
concerne en particulier trois personnes
et le dernier qui concerne toute
personne citée dans le rapport
susceptibles de donner lieu à des
enquêtes à la diligence du parquet donc
nous faisons cela voyez-vous ensemble en
prenant nos responsabilités et on en
ayant conscience vraiment de faire en
conscience ce qui nous est demandé par
la constitution de notre république
merci cher collègue madame jourdain oui
merci monsieur le président les petits
mangent m'associer aux propos qui
viennent d'être retenus et bien qu'il
s'agisse d'une prérogative du président
de la commission jean pierre sueur et
moi même nous avons tenu à nous associer
à ce courrier en responsabilité
le contrôle du parlement est une
fonction qui le marqueur de la
démocratie donc il nous paraissait
essentiel que cette fonction soit
respectée et pour cela effectivement il
ne faut pas que l'on puisse mentir et ne
pas dire la vérité lors des commissions
d'information de commission d'enquêté
des missions d'information que nous
menons et il nous apparaissait essentiel
de saisir le bureau du sénat pour que le
parquet puisse à son tour être saisi sur
ce point eh bien merci chers collègues
merci de votre patience mesdames et
messieurs il se pourrait qu'il y ait une
ou plusieurs questions s'il vous plaît
je suis calme et je travaille pour
public sonaca regarde ce que vous portez
sur la pression qui a été exercée sur la
commission depuis le mois de juillet il
ya les mots destitution qui ont été
prononcées qui était une volonté qu'on
vous prêtait et également le fait que
voilà il y avait cette expression qu'il
vienne me chercher
quel regard que vous portez sur cette
pression assez phénoménal aussi la part
de la garde des sceaux qui a qu'à
attaquer vos travaux en termes de
séparation des pouvoirs est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire votre sentiment sur
cette question celle écume des choses
c'était il ya longtemps c'est à dire il
y a quatre mois et nous n'avons pas
attachés à ces tentatives de créer la
polémique ou de pression la moindre
importance
senna est libre et indépendant il a fait
son travail avec sérénité avec humilité
aussi en s'efforçant de répondre à la
tante d'objectivité qui je crois a été
placée en lui il n'y a rien à ajouter
sauf peut-être que je veux remercier de
la qualité de leur collaboration
l'ensemble des personnes aux réserves
que nous avons indiqué tout à l'heure
qui ont été auditionnés mais aussi vous
dire que je suis très heureux comme les
rapporteurs d'avoir pu rassembler à la
part à partir de nos demandes écrites
une documentation très volumineuse
puisque elle atteint près de 500 pages
qui a comporté beaucoup d'éléments
d'information dont vous avez trouvé la
trace dans l'exposé des deux rapporteurs
et qui s'ajoute aux informations que
nous avons recueillies recueillies en
audition
bonjour azzeddine ahmed-chaouch pour
quotidien oui on a le sentiment que ce
sous le pression on a le sentiment que
c'est sous la pression de votre travail
au sénat et du travail de journaliste
que la sphère puis avancez jusqu au
placement en détention provisoire hier
d'alexandre benalla question la justice
et elle at-elle été trop lente dans
cette affaire et deuxième question
sommes-nous selon vont présence d'un
scandale d'état
ce n'est pas aujourd'hui après avoir été
si sourcilleux si vigilant dans le
respect du travail de la justice que
nous avons aujourd'hui et les
rapporteurs et moi même faire des
commentaires sur le travail de la
justice quant à la qualification de ce
qu'est cette affaire benalla ça n'a
aucune importance ce qui est important
pour nous c'est que nous avons constaté
des dysfonctionnements nous avons
proposé des recommandations pour qu'il
soit plus fin il y à d'ailleurs été mis
fin avant même une recommandation pour
un certain nombre de ces
dysfonctionnements effectivement grâce à
un bon fonctionnement de notre
démocratie auquel le parlement à travers
nous je crois aura eu sa part mais les
médias eux mêmes rues une grande part
dans ce résultat
et ça ça inspire de la confiance dans le
fonctionnement des institutions de notre
pays
et puis ça montre toute l'importance en
démocratie de mettre sous le regard des
nos concitoyens des françaises et des
français en l'occurrence ce qui ne va
pas pour que se soit améliorée monsieur
sûr je voulais ajouter un complément
mais pas sur ça j'aurais été un peu
frustré suite à votre question je
voulais quand même saluer l'effort de
rhétorique de madame le garde des sceaux
qui nous a gratifié d'une dissertation
dans le journal le monde pour nous
expliquer
l'article 51 alinéa 2 de la constitution
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait un effort que
je tiens à saluer nous étions nous
avions lu par nous mêmes la constitution
et je voulais dire que très très
aimablement comme toujours que s'il
était tout à fait intéressant de voir
que les autorités de l'exécutif était
très préoccupé du fait que nous n'avons
piétions pas nous pouvoir législatif sur
le pouvoir le judiciaire elle pourrait
aussi s'interroger sur l'utilité de pour
le pouvoir exécutif
deux passes empiéter sur les
prérogatives du pouvoir législatif
voilà c'est fini et réciproquement et
nous y sommes attentifs aux prérogatives
de chaque institution madame jourda wipo
pour répondre également à cette première
question de quentin qu'elle met des mots
forts ont été prononcées c'est vrai
comme le mode destitution je pense que
la restitution de nos travaux
aujourd'hui aura permis d'apaiser des
craintes si elle existait encore nous
sommes concentrés sur le fonctionnement
de l'état et est nullement sur ce qu on
nous prêtait comme intention que nous
n'avons jamais eu madame janyk et emily
du parisien j'essaie de comprendre les
conclusions auxquelles vous arrive et il
me semble que vous faites mais je peux
être me tromper je des distinctions
entre omissions mensonges contradictions
et faux témoignages notamment pour
messieurs benalla et monsieur kraz est
ce que je me trompe ou est ce le cas
est-ce que ça entraîne des conséquences
différentes sur le ce que vous allez
demander à au bureau de
du sénat monsieur sur a par avance ce
répondu à cette question montre en effet
il y à une distinction entre les trois
cas que vous citez le cas de monsieur
benalla le cas des collaborateurs du
président de la république qui au début
de notre travail ont opposé des
dénégations
une question que nous posions sur
l'exercice de responsabilités en matière
de sécurité par monsieur benalla avant
que la présidence de la république
elle-même admettent des responsabilités
de sécurité de monsieur benalla quelques
semaines après au moment où nous avions
demandé communication de la fiche de
fonctions de l'intéressé et puis comme
ceux sur la expliqué tout à l'heure il y
a dans les témoignages reçus des
contradictions et quand il ya des
contradictions il y en a des les auteurs
de ces contradictions
certains ont dit la vérité et d'autres
pas mais nous ne sommes pas en mesure
les opposant les uns aux autres de
savoir et il appartiendra au procureur
de la république s'il est saisi
d'apprécier s'il y a lieu qu'il
approfondisse ses contradictions pour
déterminer l'existence éventuelle là
aussi de faux témoignage est attribuée
de tels faux témoignage à leurs auteurs
ce que nous sommes incapables de faire
quand deux personnes nous disent des
choses qui s'opposent
si nous n'avons pas suffisamment
d'éléments de fait pour trancher entre
leurs témoignages et savoir qui dit vrai
et qui dit faux et puis il peut arriver
aussi que quelqu'un dise faut de bonne
foi et sans et sans mentir
donc vous voyez que quand les questions
se poseront à la justice elle portera
une appréciation différente de celle que
nous bout pour porter et avec des moyens
différents
nous avons nous le serment mais nous
n'avons pas la garde à vue
nous n'avons pas toutes les dix sociaux
que peu utilisé la justice quand elle
poursuit la recherche de la vérité sur
d'éventuelles infractions
ainsi s'achevait oui permettez moi ça
veut dire le ce que vous appelez ce que
vous n'appelez pas officiellement si je
puis dire ou juridiquement je ne sais
pas faux témoignages que vous appelez
omission contradictions et mensonges je
crois vous vous préconisez en tout cas
vous proposer tout de même que ça puisse
l'objet de la saisine du procureur
monsieur tu vas vous précisez soyons
extrêmement clair la lettre vous l'avez
donc vous pouvez la lire vous l'avez
tous un dans le dossier bon il est tout
à fait clair que dans tous les cas nous
proposons au président du sénat et au
bureau du sénat de saisir le parquet
c'est clair premièrement pour monsieur
benalla écrase avec des formules que
nous avons écrites et que j'ai lu tout à
l'heure donc c'est clair
en parlant de faux témoignages
deuxièmement nous demandons que pour les
collaborateurs de l'elysée précités le
parquet soit saisie au nom d'omissions
d'incohérences et de contradictions et
au nom du fait que les personnes
concernées ont retenu une part
significative de la vérité à la
commission et troisièmement nous
proposons que soient envoyées l'ensemble
du rapport c'est à dire le rapport
lui-même plus la lettre qui annexe et
plus les témoignages qui sont annexés à
la lettre si vous lisez l'ensemble des
témoignages vous verrez qu'il y a
matière à s'interroger sur un certain
nombre de personnes qui n'ont pas été
précédemment cités mais qui sont dans le
rapport
et enfin est aussi annexée au rapport
l'ensemble des comptes rendus des
auditions
donc nous nous disons ce que nous
croyons devoir dire en conscience par
rapport aux différentes personnes
non que nous avons cités et avec les
qualificatifs que nous avons définies et
nous en prenons la responsabilité mais
dans les trois cas il s'agit de saisir
le parquet avec des motivations que nous
assumons mais dans le troisième cas
c'est une saisine très large car nous
avons le sentiment que cette saisine
large et en l'espèce absolument
justifiés
sans cela nous n'aurions pas indiqué
dans la lettre je crois que c'est clair
ça j'espère merci je fais ce que je suis
en messieurs où ils bonjour simon le
baron de france info pour compléter la
question de ma consoeur du parisien est
ce que vous pouvez nous re préciser nos
résumés quels sont les omissions les
contradictions les incohérences que vous
avez enlevé dans les déclarations de
monsieur strzoda colère et la vernhe il
y en a sept pages monsieur alors je vous
recommande de d'en prendre connaissance
puisque tout est rendu public
dans le détail nous n'allons pas lire
les sept pages devant vous on a tiré sur
on a tout impossible
on a tout dit impossible que je fais de
la radio c'est pour s'exprimer bien sûr
mais du faux et là je nous comptons sur
votre travail de journaliste pour
informer vos auditeurs à partir de la
totale transparence que nous avons fait
et j'ai ici et nous sommes à votre
disposition dans la radio voilà
la lasure à ses bras se calmait j'avais
une deuxième question est ce que vous
avez travaillé sur tout ce qui s'est
passé depuis depuis les faits de la
place de la contrescarpe est ce qu'il
pourrait y avoir une autre commission d'
enquête notamment sur la question des
passeports diplomatiques est ce que vous
proposez à vos collègues sénateurs de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
vous voilà de vous de vous suivre et
vous emboîter le pas dans dans ses
travaux parce qu'il ya encore des choses
à découvrir selon vous elle c'est une
question qui peut se poser maintenant
vous avez beaucoup d'idées pour nous
celle là ne l'avions pas lui pour les
passeports diplomatiques
la chose essentielle c'est quand même
que monsieur benhaddad demande le
renouvellement du passeport le jour même
où il est déchargé de toutes les
missions de toutes les fonctions qui
justifierait qu'il est un passeport
diplomatique qui le demandent
directement sans passer par le service
du protocole de l'elysée il obtient le
nul de quai d'orsay ea dont dix au
service du protocole qui lui a délivré
le passeport
et il ne se passe rien c'est à dire que
le service du protocole ignorent sans
doute le fait que monsieur pénale a été
chargé des fonctions en raison
desquelles il a obtenu par cette voix
étrange un passeport à un moment où il
n'en avait il a eu le droit d'en avoir
voyez c'est le signe que tous this
fonctionne et un peu se déglingue à
partir du moment où les gens pensent que
c'est monsieur b dallas et qu'il a une
autorité particulière même chose et bien
mesdames et messieurs je vous remercie
beaucoup de l'intérêt que vous avez de
nouveau portée à nos travaux et je vous
souhaite bon courage maintenant parce
que c'est vous qui prenez le relais
la conférence de presse est terminée
voilà pour ce verdict du sénat à verdict
attendu mais implacable de la part de la
haute assemblée qui a donc présenté ce
matin 13 propositions pour améliorer la
sécurité du président de la république
le sénat qui pointe des
dysfonctionnements majeurs dans la
sécurité du président mais qui frappe
également un grand coup en annonçant et
bien avoir saisi le bureau du sénat en
vue d'une saisine de la justice pour les
faux témoignage à la fois d'alexandre
benalla mais aussi de vincent kraz et
puis il se pourrait bien que c'est cette
saisine soit élargie aussi aux cas
d'alexis colère le secrétaire général de
l'elysée de patrick strzoda directeur de
cabinet des manuels macro mais aussi du
colonel lionel lavergne c'était c'est
lui le chef du groupement de sécurité de
la présidence de la république tous les
trois pourrait avoir et bien menti par
omission va bien sûr en parler avec mes
invités sur ce plateau trois sénateurs
tous membres de cette commission d'
enquête sénatoriale qui m'ont rejoint
l'instant nathalie delattre bonjour
merci d'être avec nous sénatrice rds de
la gironde de jacqueline eustache brinio
est également avec nous vous êtes
sénatrice et l'air du val d'oise et puis
jérôme durain sénateur socialiste de
saône et loire
merci à tous les trois on entendu un ce
rapport très sévère
nathalie delattre il faut dire que vous
avez à me former des dysfonctionnements
graves
oui je voudrais souligner leur apport
très méticuleux et salué le travail de
nos rapporteur je pense que il est
construit dans une logique qui montrent
effectivement l'ensemble de ces
dysfonctionnements
tout d'abord une confiance accrue donnée
par la présidence de la république à un
individu qui fait que cela dysfonctionne
c'est à dire que on est dans un jeu de
c'est pas moi c'est lui de retenue de
fébrilité de l'exécutif qui fait qu'il
n'y a pas de décision prise ou les
décisions prises ne sont pas bonnes
ensuite nous avons la conviction à qui
cette conviction très forte que
alexandre reynal a fait de la protection
rapprochée et que du fait de ce rôle
très important et un peu inédit sous la
vème république
il va même plus loin puisqu'il veut
s'arroger ce pouvoir pour lui et faire
en sorte qu'il y ait une déconnexion
avec le ministère de
donc là on va effectivement très très
loin et puis ensuite on voit que tout ce
qui a été raconté sous couvert de cette
histoire que l'on l'appuyant entretenir
de la part des collaborateurs de
l'elysée sur théorème sur les passeports
sur le port d'armes on voit bien que
tout cela était mis à ce service là et
que ce que l'ont effectivement nous a
dit ne tient pas n'est pas n'est pas
sérieux et là on démontre tous ces
dysfonctionnements et enfin on parle des
contrats russe où là on touche à
l'éthique de la république et on en voit
bien que alors soit c'est une succession
de négligence ou bien on a affaire un
système qui s'est mis en place très
libérale et non et très permissif par
rapport à cette façon de faire et je
pense qu'ensuite et la décision de
saisir par le président bah le président
larcher pour faux témoignage
informations retenues et effectivement
et les propositions qui sont rendus dans
le rapport sont tout à fait logique et
font honneur au sénat jacques une salle
vrignaud ce rapport il a été adopté à la
quasi unanimité il ya eu trois
abstentions les deux sénateurs en marche
alain richard et arnaud de belenet votre
collègue aussi jean françois husson
sénateur non inscrit
on va réagir mais on retombe tout de
suite foyer clemenceau puisque philippe
bas le président de cette commission
denquête est avec vous êtes en train de
nuit
oui philippe bas tout d'abord et bien un
retour sur tout ce que vous allez
transmettre au bureau du sénat pour à la
fois et bien des faux témoignages et des
retenues significative de la vérité
alors vous parlez
pour ce dernier point notamment d'alexis
colère de patrick strzoda et de lionel
lavergne c'est à dire et bien de hauts
personnages au sein de l'elysée
vous avez tout ceci c'est en quelques
sortes la pointe extrême de notre
travail
ce que
voulant retenir nous d'abord c'est que
nous avons contribué à l'oeuvre de
vérité sous le regard des français avec
transparence que chacun peut maintenant
se faire son propre jugement
et ça c'est la mission démocratique
d'une assemblée parlementaire c'est sa
prérogative et cette prérogative
s'exerce au nom du peuple français et en
vertu de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen la société a le
droit de demander compte à tout agent
public de son administration et nous le
faisons nous au nom de la société au nom
des français
sous son regard et le fait que ça a été
entièrement public
ça a permis vraiment à notre démocratie
d'exercer une sorte de droit de regard
sur le fonctionnement de l'état pour
l'améliorer que les règles soient
respectées c'est pour ça que nous avons
fait beaucoup de propositions très
simple d'ailleurs pour qu'il n'y ait
aucune défaillance de dysfonctionnements
que nous avons constatées et ça pour ça
me tient très à coeur de vous le dire
parce que c'est pour nous le poids est
essentielle de notre mission notre
mission n'aurait eu que ce résultat qui
serait déjà le plus important c'est
important de rappeler ça pendant le
grand débat notamment alors que l'on
parle beaucoup des institutions alors
que parfois et bien le scénario remise
en cause
alors oui je crois que le sénat parce
qu'il est libre
parce qu'il est indépendant parce qu'il
est non alignés dans les pouvoirs
publics constituent constitutionnel pour
reprendre une expression très juridique
il est le seul à pouvoir réellement
apporter ce rôle de contre-pouvoir de
contrepoids qui peut éclairer les
français quand un sujet de préoccupation
émergent et c'est ce que vraiment c'est
ce que nous avons voulu faire avec
muriel jourda et jean pierre sueur qui
sont les deux rapporteurs de notre
commission
et puis toute la commission et nous
avons constamment
est attentif à bien respecter notre
mandat à respecter les prérogatives de
la justice mais aussi les prérogatives
du président de la république dont nous
n'avons pas le droit d'examiner les
actes et les décisions et nous nous
sommes bien gardé de le faire il nous
n'avons pas le droit non plus de nous
prononcer sur des infractions qui
peuvent avoir été commise par monsieur
benalla par monsieur kraz qui
travaillait avec lui parce que ça c'est
la justice et donc nous avons été à la
fois très très scrupuleux pour le
respect de nos institutions
et nous avons aussi été très soucieux
que les français accède à toute
l'information dont ils avaient besoin
pour se faire un jugement philippe bas
je reviens à ma première question sur le
fait que vous parlez du fait qu alexis
un colère de patrick strzoda c'est à
dire le secrétaire général de l'elysée
le directeur de cabinet des manuels
macron et le colonel lavergne le chef du
j'espère ont retenu une part
significative de la vérité tout le monde
le sait parce que si vous voulez au
début de nos auditions nous avons
c'était le sujet majeur nous avons
demandé est ce que monsieur vénale
avaient des responsabilités en matière
de sécurité
il nous a été répondu que non et au mois
de septembre alors que nous avions
demandé la fiche de poste de monsieur
benalla et que nous étions sur le point
de l'obtenir la présidence de la
république aravot connus et s'est
inscrit dans la fiche de poste que
monsieur benalla exerçaient une fonction
de coordination des services de sécurité
il nous est apparu qu'il exerçait
également une fonction de garde du corps
avec cette position caractéristiques de
l'action d'un de protection rapprochée
qui est la position à l'épaule avec ce
permis de port d'armes qui n'aurait
aucune raison
ainsi monsieur benalla n'exerçait pas à
l'époque une fonction de garde du corps
et nous avons dit donc la vérité a été
retenu mais vous savez notre souci à
nous c'est de dire au fond nous exerçons
au nom des français
un droit fondamental qui est le leur qui
est le droit d'exercer un contrôle sur
le bon fonctionnement de l'état et donc
si nous voulons faire émerger la vérité
qu'on nous ment alors
parlement ne peut pas remplir ce rôle au
nom des français et c'est à droits des
français qui se trouvent ainsi bafoué et
par conséquent c'est très important et
c'est ça notre état d'esprit c'est de
faire en sorte que le droit que nous
exerçons nous la représentation
nationale au nom des français soient
pleinement respectés alors en même temps
je dois dire que nous avons eu une très
bonne coopération y compris des mêmes
autorités
elle travaille à la présidence de la
république sur les autres points qui
faisait l'objet de notre enquête et nous
ne sommes pas nous dans une sorte de
vindicte nous nous nous relevons
simplement les compteurs nous constatons
des contradictions qui nous paraissent
justifiés que le procureur de la
république pour défendre le parlement
ouvre une enquête
qu'on sache bien en france qu on n'a pas
le droit de mentir j'ai déjà une
commission d' enquête parlementaire j'ai
une toute dernière question très rapide
vous avez parlé de faux témoignage lors
de la conférence de presse pour
alexandre benalla pour vincent kraz dans
le rapport vous citer également et yann
drouet le chef de cabinet du préfet de
police de paris
est ce que vous pensez aussi que d'un
faux témoignage de sa part est ce que
vous le transmettez aussi directement au
bureau n'a pas souhaité que le procureur
de la république soit spécifiquement nac
saisie de son cas mais il est vrai que
nous avons fait une liste de propos
contradictoires que nous avons entendus
et qu'il est cité dans ses
contradictions il appartiendra puisque
nous avons donné tout le rapport au
procureur de la république
il appartiendra au procureur de la
république de déterminer si 200 points
de vue du point de vue de la justice qui
s'impose à tous il y a eu pour lui et
sans doute quelques autres des faux
témoignages
mais nous ne l'avons pas souhaité la
criminelle nommément merci beaucoup
philippe bas d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup a atteint pour cette
première réaction directe du président
de cette commission denquête à le
sénateur philippe à jacqueline eustache
brinio on entendu infinie bas a rappelé
les conditions de sérénité dans lesquels
avaient travaillé
le sénat le sénat est libre nous at il
dit c'est vrai que cette commission
denquête elle a pu déranger au plus haut
sommet de l'état
elle a probablement pu déranger mais je
pense que cette commission depuis son
installation avait un seul souci c'était
la vérité et elle était dans ce rôle
puisque le sénat a pour mission aussi de
protéger le bon fonctionnement de l'état
je pense que physiquement quand on voit
ce qui s'est passé à l'assemblée
nationale où la commission a explosé en
vol même peut-être décollage
heureusement que le sénat était là parce
que quand on s'aperçoit ce qui s'est
passé en juillet avec la commission à
l'assemblée s'est stoppé tout de suite
et quand on voit aujourd'hui tout ce
parcours
toutes ces informations que nous avons
eues ces dysfonctionnements qui ont été
posées grâce à cette commission nous
gâte et je dois dire que cette
commission denquête lcl a vécu avec une
grande sérénité voilà pas dans un esprit
partisan pas dans un esprit de se dire
c'est le président la tête du processeur
sera d'un tout entendu quand même à
destituer enfin mon projet non c'était
un souci de vérité et c'était de se dire
cette cette affaire banale art elle est
quand même significatif
dysfonctionnements au plus haut niveau
de l'état
une vraie réalité ça et aujourd'hui
quand on voit ce qui est écrit dans ce
rapport les frais sans madame jourda et
monsieur soeurs ont mené ces débats de
manière exceptionnelle c'était voilà où
on voit bien la qualité de ce qui est
écrit aujourd'hui on voit ce
dysfonctionnement il existe les
mensonges ils sont là les incohérences
elles sont là il va bien falloir que à
toutes ces explications qui nous n'osons
pas été donnée la vérité elle n'a pas
été toujours là dans les échanges que
nous avons eus il ya aujourd'hui on va
pouvoir enfin avoir toutes les réponses
et toutes les attentes que nous avons
aujourd'hui elles sont écrites et elles
sont là et on peut se poser la question
parce que ça a été dit c'est on peut se
poser la question du uniquement par
rapport à la présence d'un puce et le
problème de la confiance que le
président a dû donner mais c'est pas
mieux si je suis pas accusatrice quand
je dis ça c'est probablement ça aussi le
problème c'est comment se fait-il que le
président a donné
une telle confiance à cet homme pascal
et la voilà c'est pas c'est aussi une
question qui va falloir se poser et
peut-être que les interrogations que
nous avons posée ce matin parce qu'il va
y avoir prononcée suite bien peut-être
qu'il y aura aussi s'imposer avec une
place excessive un présentation benallal
jérôme durand c'est ce qui ressort de ce
rapport
oui moi ce qui m'intéresse à ce stade
après que nos deux co rapporteurs ont
rendu ce rapport et après cette
conférence de presse
c'est de mettre en perspective ce que la
commission denquête apporte comme
élément avec tout ce qu'on a vécu depuis
le début de la faire on a commencé par
nous dire c'est une affaire d'été et on
voit que c'est nina faire d'été ni un
fait divers de mauvais jumeaux c'est
quand même quelque chose qui touche au
fonctionnement de l'état dans des
dimensions qu'on n'avait pas soupçonné à
l'époque la sphère des contrats russe
c'est quand même les intérêts
stratégiques de l'état c'est quand même
notre souveraineté nationale
c'est un coin dans l'exécutif dans le
coeur de la république qui est posée
deuxième dimension
c'était
le procès en cabale politique on nous a
dit benjamin griveaux la ministre de la
justice elle même on nous a parlé de
déontologie on nous a parlé de
d'ingérence ce rapport il est sévère
mais juste il est argumenté il est
étayée on fait notre travail
troisième dimension c'est le loup
solitaire l'homme isolé
l'individu qui part en vrille non il ya
des dysfonctionnements en chaîne et
c'est toute l'organisation de la
présidence de la république parce que
dans cette affaire c'est pas la personne
du président la turquie nous intéresse
la fonction fitch fait les
fonctionnaires et puis dernière chose
juste avant une question de deux
réformes institutionnelles ce qui pose
problème dans ce pays
est ce que c'est le fonctionnement du
parlement ou est ce que c'est les
dérives de la monarchie républicaine
telle qu'elle s'exerce à l'elysée je
pense que tout le monde râle et
événements pour se faire une idée on va
bien sûr seul point ont continué leur
action avec vos alterne tran huy puisque
vous êtes aux côtés d'une des coûts
rapporteur de cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire c'est la sénatrice
et l'air du morbihan un muriel jourda
oui muriel jourda il ya eu donc des
dysfonctionnements cascade au sein de
l'elysée
vous parlez de retenue d'informations de
la part est bien de hauts fonctionnaires
de l'elysée il s'agit d'alexis colère de
patrick strzoda de lionel lavergne est
ce que aujourd'hui pour vous tout cela
est désormais une affaire d'état alors
une affaire d'état
j'avoue que la qualification m'importe
peu ce qui est certain c'est qu'il ya eu
des dysfonctionnements et qu'il est
important de les corriger
voire par la saisine du parquet pour que
cela ne se renouvelle pas que devant une
commission denquête on ne monte pas au
pouvoir parlementaire qui exerce son
pouvoir de contrôle
est-ce que c'est difficile justement il
vient de travailler correctement lorsque
l'on voit est bien toutes les saisines
que vous allez faire de faux témoignage
mais aussi de retenue d'information
écoutez nous avons pu quand même à
travailler assez sereinement parce que
nous avons été assez imperméable aux
pressions qui se sont abattues sur nous
si je puis dire au moment où nous avons
indiqué que nous souhaitions entendre
monsieur benalla mais je dois dire ce
temps est assez éloignée désormais nous
avons pu finir très sereinement nous
travaux ensuite il est important que ce
qui nous a été dit soit l'exacte vérité
ça nous allons à vérifier vous dites que
c'est assez éloigné tout à l'heure jean
pierre charras bien saluer la rhétorique
de la cheffe de la pardon de la garde
des sceaux nicole belloubet et de la
dissertation qu'elle avait produit sur
la séparation des pouvoirs
non le monde lorsque justement il est
peut-être question d'auditionner
alexandre benalla c'est vrai mais c'est
encore une fois ces anciens et puis
c'était tout à fait exact rhétorique
juridique et nous avons d'ailleurs
veillé à ce que cette séparation divorce
a bien respecté
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire de plus
aujourd'hui comme en tant que commission
d'enquêté est ce que vous pouvez faire
plus que simplement transmettre le
rapport au président de la république et
au premier au premier ministre non mais
nous allons le faire nous allons les
transmettre et ça me paraît déjà
important nous avons travaillé dans
l'intérêt des institutions dans
l'intérêt du fonctionnement de l'état et
ça me paraît important que nos
propositions soient suivies d'effets il
appartiendra bien évidemment à ces
institutions ne sont emparés ou pas mais
j'espère qu'elle s'en empareront corse
est destiné véritablement à améliorer la
qualité du travail des institutions est
également la sécurité du président de la
république or personne ne peut s'en
désintéresser et surtout pas au plus
haut niveau de l'état
un mot enfin il n'assure le nombre de
saisines qui vont être effectués ça n'a
jamais eu lieu
la première fois qu'il ya eu un par jour
devant une commission d'enquêté a été
transmis au bureau du sénat ce n'est en
2016 et le professeur michel aubier est
là et bien vous transmettez
l'intégralité de votre rapport c'est
dire le nombre de faux témoignages et le
monde retenu d'informations que vous
suspectez en réalité nous n'avons pas la
certitude que tout ce que nous
transmettons constituer un faux
témoignage c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'il faut le soumettre à l'appréciation
bien le préparer
c'est le parquet qui en décide nous
avons un certain nombre de propos qui
sont contradictoires qui nous a dit la
vérité qui ne nous l'a pas dit et est-ce
que celui qui nous a pas dit la vérité
savait qu'il ne nous disait pas la
vérité
les choses sont un peu plus complexes et
à dire qu'on peut parfaitement retenir
une information tout simplement parce
qu'on ne l'avait pas donc tout ce qui
nous est apparu par souci d'exhaustivité
recel et une incohérence ou une
contradiction
nous l'avons transmis mais en
transmettant à titre principal un
certain nombre d'éléments qui nous
paraissait assez proche d'être autre
chose qu'une commission aucune
incohérence est plus proche du faux
témoignage bien sûr mais à jourda pour
conclure vous avez dit tout à l'heure ce
n'était pas un homme isolé c'était bien
un système le système était grippée je
retiens notamment qu'il avait même été
envisagé un décret secret pour
qu'alexandre benalla puissent bénéficier
d'un port d'armes un décret secret du
président de la république alors ça
avait été envisagée par monsieur benalla
lui même qui lorsqu'il avait demandé un
port d'armes car c'est une demande qu'il
faisait de façon récurrente au moins
depuis 2012 puisque la première trace
que nous en avons et bien ils avaient
envisagé de moyens légaux qui existent
plus ce décret du président de la
république donc ils pensaient qu'il ne
pleuve qu'il pouvait ne pas être publié
au journal officiel
je dois à la vérité de dire que ça n'a
jamais été retenu par l'elysée et pour
le reste tout de même vous estimez que
le système entier est grippé aujourd'hui
à l'élysée encore aujourd'hui s'agissant
du traitement de la situation de
monsieur b d'allah oui ça a été très
clairement grecque
merci à beaucoup moyenne journalière en
réalité jamais question merci pour cette
nouvelle réaction
nathalie delattre intéressant ce que dit
à l'instant muriel jourda ce que vous
avez le sentiment mais aussi d'avoir
fait partie d'une commission d enquête
parlementaire hors norme un à la fois
par tous ces longs mois de travaux c'est
34 auditions et puis par les conclusions
et préconisations aujourd'hui et cette
saisine en disait de la haute assemblée
qui frappe un grand coup aujourd'hui
oui effectivement nous sommes dans une
situation hors norme c'est pour ça qu'il
fait c'est le rapport dans son entier
qui va être transmis par ce qu'il y a
tellement d'éléments et d'information
que nous ne pouvons pas nous seuls en
faire le tri pour savoir ce qui pourrait
intéresser la justice parce que je pense
qu'au détour des pages la justice va
trouver matière pour aller encore plus
loin par rapport à ses investigations
je pense qu'il faut remettre dans le
contexte est vrai que la sphère benalla
arrive et stop à un moment donné les
travaux sur la réforme constitutionnelle
qui avait commencé à l'assemblée
nationale et je crois qu'effectivement
aussi ce travail et c'est cette somme
considérable de travail que nous avons
pu faire nous allons et 2 des
propositions concernent étayer nos
propos sursis cette réforme
constitutionnelle revenir sur le tapis
mais en tout cas montré que nous avons
besoin d'avoir des pouvoirs
d'investigation accrue et que quand
souvent nous avons posé des questions
des avocats où certains ont dit non il y
a effectivement investigations la
justice donc nous ne pouvons pas vous
répondre je pense que voilà c'est
souvent été surjouées et qu'il faut que
nous puissions éclaircir ce point là
notamment jean moulin
mais qu'est ce qui m'intéresse dans la
période
c'est effectivement que la sphère
benalla et marque le coup d'arrêt d'un
cycle politique si on situe dans le
champ politique il ya 2017
il ya la prétention d'une formation
politique à incarner le nouveau monde et
la sphère benalla c'est l'iceberg sur
lequel vient se s'effondrer sombrer le
titanic du nouveau monde parce que
finalement il n'y a pas de nouveau monde
il ya une monarchie républicaine avec
ses travers avec ses mauvaises habitudes
et alexandre benalla incarne un
sentiment d'impunité de toute puissance
dans cet appareil d'état et ce qui amène
l'ensemble des personnes qui ont été
auditionnées à avoir des petites
amodiations avec la vérité des retenues
avec la vérité des faux témoignages
peut-être parfois donc ce qui est
important si on en tire toutes les
conséquences c'est qu'on rétablisse dans
le nouveau cycle politique s'ouvre la
place des institutions les unes par
rapport aux autres et qu'on voit que le
travail parlementaire quand il est bon
niveau quand il se fait avec l'intérêt
national à l'esprit en premier lieu il
est essentiel il est déterminant il est
nécessaire donc peut-être que si la
réforme constitutionnelle comme le dit
nathalie delattre doit advenir
on en gardera le meilleur à l'esprit oui
je partage complètement les propos de
mes deux collègues et c'est vrai que
encore récemment le sénat était quand
même dans la ligne de mire de beaucoup
quand même en 10 ans sert à rien mais
compris dans la bouche de certains qui
est haut placé moi j'ai envie de dire
que aujourd'hui on nous a interrogés
souvent sur est une affaire d'état c'est
palm os mais c'est une affaire qui se
situe au plus haut niveau de l'état
c'est pas rien ça se passe à l'elysée
avec le président de la république et
ses collaborateurs
ça ne peut pas lier personne peut le
nier ça se situe à ce niveau là donc il
était important aujourd'hui qu'on fasse
ce travail pour remettre un petit peu
les choses à leur place
est ce que mon collègue a dit à
l'instant c'est évidement politiquement
important de le dire aussi parce
qu'effectivement d'anciens mandé le
mouvement se sont confrontés depuis un
an et demi
tout ce qu'ils étaient avant c'était
mauvais et tout ce qui était fait
parfois 10 à partir de 2017 c'était
fabuleux
on s'aperçoit depuis un an et demi que
la pyramide s'écroule et qu'il y a des
codes et qu'il y a des règles et qu'il
fa il faut les connaître aussi et il
faut les respecter parce qu'aujourd'hui
ce qui s'est passé c'est que avec cette
affaire dite benalla il ya quand même
beaucoup l'école les règles les
fonctionnements comment on peut imposer
aux citoyens certain nombre de codes et
de règles si au plus haut sommet de
l'état on ne les appliquent pas soi même
donc je pense que ça c'est important de
dire et moi je suis ravi d'avoir fait
partie de l'ancien monde et d'être
toujours là aujourd'hui on va continuer
à l'air avec senseur très bientôt
puisque françois noël buffet sénateur et
l'air du rhône va nous rejoindre dans un
instant on disait il ya quand même des
préconisations assez forte
nathalie delattre elle concerne
justement est bien en finir avec les
collaborateurs officieuse ça ça fait
partie des préconisations de ses tresses
préconisations du rapport à la taille de
la wii c'est incompréhensible du monde
de l'entreprise par exemple c'est vrai
que l'état a pris l'habitude d'avoir des
règles dérogatoires par rapport aux
normales à savoir des cdd à répétition
des collaborateur officieux
je crois que ça permet nous avons eu un
travail en toute transparence et cela a
effectivement permis à des français de
s'apercevoir qu'il y avait des pratiques
qui n'étaient pas à l'honneur de la
république et de l'état
donc oui c'est ses collaborateur
officieux doit bien évidemment
disparaître de ses organigramme ne
devrait pas apparaître
merci on va continuer les réactions
voici jacques une salle vrignaud merci
d'avoir été avec moi françois noël
buffet on faisait ce verdict du sénat il
était attendu il est implacable les
conclusions sont sévères notamment ce
qui concerne de graves
dysfonctionnements au sommet de l'état
que pouvait-on attendre d'autre que du
sénat qu'une que l'exercice de sa
liberté de son indépendance pour dire ce
qu'il en est de la situation rien
d'autre que la vérité
et je crois que le sénat en tous les cas
la commission des lois sous forme de
commission denquête a été intransigeante
à tous points de vue
au contraire est extrêmement exigeante
dans son travail c'est une bonne chose
je crois c'est une garantie
extraordinaire institutionnelle du
fonctionnement de notre démocratie dans
la ces dans le rôle de séparation des
pouvoirs est dans le pouvoir de contrôle
qu'exerce le sénat donc
institutionnellement c'est quelque chose
pour moi d'essentiel sur le fond de la
décision
oui le sénat a beaucoup travaillé les
auditions étaient complètes
l'analyse de nos rapporteur a été
extrêmement minutieuses et ils nos
conclusions ne pouvait être qu'à la
hauteur du travail qui a été fait et ce
travail vous connaissez désormais la
décision et les confins les conclusions
de ce travail des observations et des
préconisations dans l'organisation de
l'état est à son plus haut niveau dans
le rôle des collaborateurs dans la
définition des missions dans les
capacités dans les autorités de contrôle
de façon à ce que ne se reproduise pas
c'est que nous venons de connaître
peut-être cela est il existait avant
j'en sais rien dans tous les cas les
circonstances ont fait qu'elles ont été
révélées maintenant donc cette
clarification cette transparence est
nécessité de confiance dont nous avons
besoin au plus haut niveau de l'état
et puis bien sûr sur la partie des faits
eux mêmes la saisine du président du
sénat qui saisira le bureau afin de
t'autorise et a saisi le procureur de la
république sur les éléments de parjure
de mensonges de monsieur bénalia de
monsieur kraz devant cette commission
denquête on ne ment pas impunément
devant une institution de la république
surtout lorsque de surcroît on a prêté
serment de dire la vérité
il ya aussi une forme claire de message
clair envoyé à ceux qui aujourd'hui ou
demain pourrait comparaître devant
comparaître est auditionné pardon par
une commission denquête qu' on ne dit on
ne prête pas serment de dire la vérité
et on s'accommoderait de cette
prestation de serment donc ça aussi
c'est un élément de crédibilité est
censé rappeler à jean pierre servent à
nous rejoindre également sur ce plateau
un des co rapporteur de cette commission
d' enquête parlementaire installez-vous
jean-pierre soeur jours le diront on
vient d'entendre françois noël buffet
c'est un sérum dans cette procédure de
saisine de la justice pour parjure c'est
arrivé une fois dans l'histoire
parlementaire et celio sena c'était en
2016 pour cette commission dont 4 sur la
pollution de l'air avec le professeur au
biais là aussi il y avait une volonté la
haute assemblée de frapper un grand coup
de frapper fort et ce qui est assez
intéressant en la matière et moi je vais
être assez optimiste sur ce sujet c'est
que nous sommes rattrapés par la sagesse
populaire et par le bon sens on était
identifié bien moins que jean pierre
sueur qui était très très en vue dans
cette affaire mais
dans nos vie courante on disait là là ça
suffit quoi falala il vous a bien baladé
et le fait qu' on siffle la fin de la
partie et qu'on dise on ne peut pas
impunément raconter n'importe quoi
devant la représentation nationale
c'est une affaire sérieuse qu'on dise à
monsieur benalla et à quelques autres
c'est une
c'est une opération de transparence qui
est nécessaire en deux une période de
défiance vis-à-vis des institutions les
autorités d'une manière générale
notamment politiques sont décriés je
crois que là il faut il fallait rétablir
une forme d'équilibré et ce qui est
assez intéressant dans les propositions
de la mission elles sont au nombre de 2
13 certaines s'intéresse à la sécurité
de la présidence de la république
d'autres à l'article 40 d'autres pouvoir
de contrôle du parlement mais on a quand
même 8
ça ne trompe pas qui concerne la
transparence dans le fonctionnement de
l'exécutif
et finalement il ya un rattrapage pour
l'exécutif de ce que le parlement a déjà
connu en matière de transparence en
matière de collaborateurs en matière de
déclaration et c'est une chose qui est
plutôt un progrès pour notre démocratie
c'est une revanche du parlement sur
l'exécutif jean pierre sueur ça les
préconisations notamment ci concerne les
obligations de transparence que je viens
d'évoquer à l'instant jean morin c'est
pas une revanche on n'est pas du tout
dans une logique de revanche
nous voulons par contre exercer
pleinement les missions qui nous sont
dévolues par la constitution
c'est à dire que dans une démocratie il
faut qu'il y ait une mis une mission de
contrôle du pouvoir exécutif
et c'est ce que nous avons fait tout
simplement par écouter aussi fini mbba
pour les spectateurs qui nous
rejoindrons principal de cette matinée
sur public sénat le sénat qui va donc
saisir la justice qui cherche donc à
voir s'il ya eu vraiment des faux
témoignages ce matin
devant la commission d'enquêté
parlementaire écouter a fini ma comme l'
ordonnance de 1958 relative à l'exercice
de ses pouvoirs dans quête par le
parlement le prévoit j'ai donc décidé
conjointement avec les deux rapporteurs
et après avoir consulté ce matin la
commission des lois de demander au
président du sénat que le bureau de
notre assemblée c'est la procédure
délibère en vue de saisir le procureur
de la république de paris
des faux témoignages caractérisée de
monsieur benalla des contradictions
apparues entre les premières
déclarations de collaborateurs immédiats
du président de la république sur le
rôle de monsieur benalla en matière de
sécurité et les éléments et témoignages
recueillis par la suite tout en
soulignant d'ailleurs la qualité et la
précision de nombreuses informations qui
nous ont été apportées par les dix
collaborateurs sur d'autres points très
importants
nous souhaitons aussi que l'ensemble du
rapport soit lui-même transmis au
procureur de la république afin qu'il
puisse apprécier l'existence éventuelle
d'autres faux témoignage susceptible
d'avoir été commis par des personnes
auditionnées
il appartient donc au bureau d'en
décider
voilà on vient d'entendre un film bat le
président de cette commission d'enquêté
parlementaire est long bien sûr il ya eu
une quasi unanimité ce matin à l'heure
de l'adoption du rapport
on le disait galut 3 abstentions les le
sénateur en marche et votre collègue
allons inscrire jean louis masson
oui sinon tout le monde a été d'accord
pour adopter ce rapport je dois vous
dire que ce n'est pas du tout un acte
politique parce que certains disent
voilà c'est de la politique politicienne
vous vous en prenez maintenant monsieur
philippe bas madame de ria jourda et moi
même nous n'appartenons pas au même
groupe politique dans ce trio la
majorité du sénat et l'opposition du
sénat est représenté comme sur ce
plateau mais seulement nous sommes
d'accord nous sommes du parti
tous deux la vérité nous n'avons pas du
tout inquiétés sur la justice notre
travail ça a été de voir comment il a pu
se faire dans notre république que la
protection prêtait une personne
l'autorité qu'on lui a prêtées eux ont
fait 10 fonctionner tout le système
parce que je peux vous dire que ce soit
à l'elysée que ce soit au ministère de
l'intérieur à la préfecture de police de
paris auquel or c'est dans les
ambassades
rien ne s'est passé comme ça devait se
passer donc qu'aux mêmes j'ajoute à
matignon puisque elles ont bien sûr mais
on donne la parole est ici à tous les
membres de cette commission d'enquêté
elle espère même massa est à vos côtés
at anfani pour une réaction
oui esther benbassa au bout de sept mois
de travaux et bien vous qu'est ce que
vous retenez qu'est-ce qui est le plus
saillant pour vous dans les conclusions
de cette commission denquête de dire
d'abord que c'est bien que nous
existions l'assemblée a arrêté les
travaux de la commission concernant la
sphère benalla et là nous nous avons su
continuer nous avons pu continuer et
c'est un acquis et et ça montre aux
françaises et aux français que nous
sommes là pour contrôler l'exécutif
aussi pour contrôler la démocratie la
bonne marche de la démo temps prenant
garde à la séparation à la séparation
des pouvoirs et là je m'en réjouis
et deuxièmement nous avons quand même
souligné
d'une manière appuyée les
dysfonctionnements de l'elysée l'opacité
des recrutements le manque de diligence
et le manque de relations entre les
différents départements pour régler les
choses par exemple c'est après ces
affaires de téléphone théorème parce
qu'en rendu non rendus etc
tout ça c'est très important quand même
et aussi bien sûr mais il y aura une
saisine enfin par c'est le bureau du
sénat qui décidera il y aura une saisine
pour mensonge sous serment contradiction
aux missions et ses unions
potentiellement très large esther
benbassa il y à alexandre benalla
vincent kraz pour faux témoignage mais
on parle aussi d'alexis colère de
patrick strzoda et de l'arnel lavage
oui bien sûr parce que concernant la
fonction de monsieur ben alla ils n'ont
pas été claires et sur d'autres points
aussi donc
il faudrait la queue qui qui passe
devant la justice ils aurient violent ni
fictif de nature jc le rapport voilà
enfin c'est le juge qui décidera s'ils
ont menti c'est pas nous mais en tout
cas monsieur benalla messieurs kraz ont
quand même menti monsieur benalla sur
ces passeports sur son affaire avec
mahmoud homme monsieur crasse aussi qui
a nié la part de monsieur d'ennahda dans
la sphère mahmoud of dans ses contrats
avec le russe mafieux et proche de
poutine
un mot enfin stable ambassades de ce qui
est ressorti de la psychologie
d'alexandre benalla il ya eu une
révélation aujourd'hui c'est
qu'alexandre benalla avait pensé même
qui pouvait y avoir un décret secret de
la part du président de la république
pour qu'il puisse avoir un port d'armes
qu'est ce que ça dit bien de la
psychologie d'alexandre benalla un homme
qui faisait à sa tête un homme ambitieux
un rastignac moderne et qui a qui a
buzzé de de l'amitié du politique qui
abuse et de l'amitié du président la
république selon merci beaucoup est à
ben bassat d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup à temps plein pour cette
année nouvelle réaction
françois noël buffet on a envie de
savoir maintenant ce qui va se passer à
partir du moment où le sénat et bien
vous demander au bureau du sénat de se
saisir des cas et bien d'alexis pas le
secrétaire général de l'elysée patrick
strzoda directeur de cabinet mme aussi
du colonel lavergne ce qu'ils peuvent
encore rester en fonctions selon vos
côtés en l'état du rapport et la demande
du bureau qui fait au bureau du sénat
c'est transmettre le dossier au
procureur de la république à charge pour
le procureur de la république de décider
s'il engage ou non des poursuites pour
les c'est pas au sénat de dire nous
engagerons des poursuites
le sénat transmet le dossier si le
parquet engage des poursuites s'il
n'engage pas de poursuites les affaires
s'arrête là et si le parquet engage des
poursuites c'est une autre discussion
qui s'ouvre évidemment quand bien même
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont la
cdus l'avocat répond que le
parlementaire
il restera selon la situation judiciaire
la présomption d'innocence mais on sent
bien qu'à un moment il pourra y avoir
effectivement des conséquences c'était
c'est clair mais nous n'en sommes pas
encore là j'allais dire général lavernhe
la situation pour l'instant c'est celle
que le bureau le président du sénat est
saisie et le dossier sera probablement
enfin tout cas c'est ce que souhaitait
la commission tran sur procure de la
pluie qui engagera des poursuites qui le
souhaitera rapidement jean legrand sur
le sais je sais que vous devez nous
quitter on ouvre une nouvelle passe
d'une crise institutionnelle avec ce
rapport du sénat aujourd'hui ça mais bon
là votre question fait plaisir parce que
c'est précisément de ça que tu en fais
parler moi je crois qu'il faut pas qu'on
reste sur l'idée qu' une nouvelle forme
d'instabilité d'instabilité va advenir
au contraire
on connaît les passions les excès les
intempérance d'un nouveau pouvoir
l'activité politique est là elle à ces
cycles et la fonction du parlement du
sénat aujourd'hui c'est plutôt de lisser
les choses de réguler donc il ya eu une
commission denquête qui rend son rapport
le pouvoir judiciaire va se saisir de ce
qu'il doit étudier et puis voilà la vie
démocratique continue je pense que toute
cette affaire
si on n'est pas dans les commentaires
dans l'excès des analyses est plutôt
rassurant pour la démocratie et je pense
de donner confiance aux citoyens dans la
république qui finalement c'est se tirer
de ce mauvais pas par la force de ses
astuces effectivement dans ce monde
défiance un peu général avec le vivant
depuis plusieurs mois pour ne pas parler
de fractions il était important aussi
que les institutions renvoi des messages
alors sans parler du cas particulier
mais le fonctionnement de l'institution
montre à l'évidence que celle ci
fonctionne qui est en capacité de mener
sa mission et que nos concitoyens
peuvent avoir confiance dans ses
institutions là au delà du sujet au delà
des personnages et ça ça me paraît
essentiel aujourd'hui que le sénat
incarne cette confiance peut-être trouvé
auprès des concitoyens on entend
tellement entre les grands débats faut
supprimer les saynètes faut supprimer le
sénat ça ne sert à rien mais la preuve
aujourd'hui par l'exemple c'est que il a
une vraie utilité institutionnels merci
à françois noël buffet est long bien sûr
il ya une volonté du sénat de réguler
d'apaiser les choses avec ce rapport ce
qui a été dit par jérôme durain et par
force au noël buffet je partage
entièrement
nous sommes sur la même ligne si vous
voulez nous au sénat on aime le débat
politique est ce que j'apprécie beaucoup
au sénat c'est que le débat politique se
fait dans le respect des personnes
zino désaccord on parle beaucoup les ça
avec les autres on vote bon voilà il ya
le débat politique mais en même temps on
sait se rassembler sur l'essentiel est
là voyez vous s'il y avait eu que
l'assemblée nationale on n'aurait pas
été très loin
pourquoi ça a explosé en vol à
l'assemblée parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
l'indépendance
et quel que soit notre position
politique
notre positionnement nous devons par
dessus tout être attaché au bon
fonctionnement de l'état républicain
or là tout le monde je veux dire que le
y compris des personnes qui
appartiennent au parti du président de
la république aux partis qui soutiennent
président de la république n'ont pas
défendu si vous voulez l'indéfendable
c'était absolument impossible dont il y
a eu des dysfonctionnements en chaîne et
c'est grave parce que l'autorité prêté à
monsieur benalla a fait que beaucoup de
gens n'ont pas fait ce qu'ils auraient
dû faire et ça c'est quelque chose de
très pernicieux pour notre démocratie
donc vous savez il ya des commissions d
enquête sur beaucoup de sujets
souvenez-vous la commission d'enquêté
sur outreau
ça a été très utile par rapport à la
justice et une commission d' enquête sur
lactalis sur beaucoup de sujets c'est
très important que le parlement exerce
sa double mission faire la loi et
contrôler le pouvoir exécutif et évaluer
les politiques publiques des missions du
sénat on va continuer les réactions
puisque votre collègue sénatrice ps
marie pierre de la gontrie et au micro
d'alexandre sa réplique toutes les
oui marie pierre de la gontrie est ce
que vous êtes satisfaite par ces six
mois de travaux de la commission
d'enquêté du sénat sur la sphère benalla
vous savez il faut être assez
pragmatique si la commission denquête
n'avait pas eu lieu rien des
dysfonctionnements voire des
irrégularités voire des infractions
pénales
et encore on a l'impression de ne pas
avoir tout découvert ce n'est d'ailleurs
pas forcément notre rôle n'aurait été
mis à jour
donc oui nous sommes satisfaits
honnêtement je pense que personne
n'imaginait que tant de placards allait
s'ouvrir et qu'on allait découvrir des
choses aussi invraisemblable donc oui
par ailleurs ça a été un travail très
sérieux
je suis dans la minorité dans
l'opposition au sénat mais ça a été un
travail de grande qualité
nous avons en permanence veiller à ne
pas déborder du cadre et de ne pas
empiéter sur la procédure judiciaire
nous avons auditionné dans des
conditions me semble-t-il
les français ont je crois ne s'y sont
pas trompés parce que c'est un succès
d'écouté incroyable d'autant que la
commission denquête jumelles de
l'assemblée avait explosé en vol au bout
de quelques jours
donc oui c'est un c'est un travail très
solide justement est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est cette enquête ces travaux ont
changé l'image du sénat
écoutez je pense qu'effectivement les
gens ont découvert
ce qui se passait au sénat parce qu'ils
ont plus l'habitude de voir ce qui se
fait à l'assemblée même si je pas sûr
qu'il sache forcément en détail ce qui
s'y fait comme travail et surtout ils
ont découvert aussi l'utilité des
contre-pouvoirs au sens large
le rôle de la presse parce que tout ça
est quand même révélé d'abord par la
presse et le rôle du sénat est donc sans
utiliser grand mot mais le bicamérisme
sert l'intérêt d'avoir une chambre qui
n'est pas
de la même couleur politique le
président de la république en place ou
bien de dire que la commission denquête
de l'assemblée c'était quand même assez
prévisible qu'elle n'avait pas loin
c'est très compliqué quand vous êtes
entièrement dans la majorité du
président en exercice et que vous
saisissez d'un sujet qui met en cause
directement dans la république de penser
que les investigations vont aller très
loin puisque vous rêviez qu'est ce que
vous répondez aux propos de la
porte-parole de la république en marche
qui juge que vous avez fait de la
politique avec cette commission
d'enquêté que c'est un précédent
dangereux
écoutez je ne connais pas ces propos je
ne sais pas qui la porte parole
d'ailleurs de la république en marche
en l'occurrence je crois qu'il ya
plusieurs choses la première chose c'est
que il faudrait qu'elle réalise la
constitution c'est à dire que les
assemblées ont la possibilité de mener
des commission denquête c'est très
important puisque aux termes de la
constitution c'est une des possibilités
justement de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement et des pouvoirs publics
point numéro un point numéro 2 elle est
députée s'il s'agit de rares berger elle
devrait savoir que par nature
nous faisons de la politique mais au
sens noble du terme et poids numéro 3 je
pense que honnêtement c'est pas très
malin de discréditer parce que les
conclusions que nous faisons c'est pour
que les choses s'améliorent
donc on pointe des choses graves des
dysfonctionnements à répétition qui se
sont enchaînés et aidera des
complaisances des négligences ou des
fautes selon les personnes
mais je trouve c'est pas très malin de
discréditer voilà merci marie pierre de
la gontrie d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci à vous alexandre poussard contre
un calme est également sur ce plateau
compte 1 journée ça public sénat vous
suivez pour nous depuis juillet
et bien cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire ça fait l'objet d'un
reportage de 26 minutes et on attend
avec impatience d'ailleurs là la saison
2 un résumé peut-être de cette matinée
que l'on attendait avec impatience
depuis 8 heures les sénateurs étaient
voilà réunis à huis clos aucune caméra
ne pouvaient approcher de la salle de la
commission des lois c'est pas faute
d'avoir essayé d'ailleurs mais
effectivement les sénateurs voulaient
travailler sereinement sans aucune va la
perturbation extérieure sur le rendu de
ce rapport puisque les rapporteurs et le
président de la commission des lois
devaient d'abord présenté à leurs
collègues elle les conclusions du
rapport pour qu'il y ait effectivement
un vote et qui valide comme ça le
contenu du rapport
on a donc cette information les
sénateurs ont quasiment à l'unanimité
voté est les conclusions du rapport à
l'exception des trois sénateurs
les deux sénateurs en marche et du
sénateur jean louis masson kiki et de
l'inscrit et donc ensuite voilà jusqu'à
11 heures
les sénateurs ont débattu des
conclusions et se sont présentés donc en
salle clemenceau pour présenter à la
presse
ce fameux rapport 1 que l'on a
maintenant ici qui présente les
conclusions est vraiment le compte rendu
de tous les travaux depuis six mois avec
les 34 audition toutes les incohérences
entre les différents témoignages et bien
sûr on retient ce qui est ce qui a été
dit sur les questions de la sécurité du
prénom république voilà la façon dont le
gspr a pu être comme cela désorganisé
par la présence et la fonction et à la
personnalité d'alexandre benalla on
retient également effectivement la
question de la sanction et la façon dont
a été gérée ensuite le départ et le
licenciement de l'excellent bénard à ce
téléphone théorème qu'il conserve les
passeports diplomatiques qui lui sont
remis tout cela et c'est effectivement
de grands dysfonctionnements de la part
de l'elysée que les sénateurs veulent
dénoncer et enfin bien sûr cette
question de la transmission au parquet
des faux témoignages
donc une certitude de la part des
sénateurs en tout cas les soupçons sont
très forts pour ce qui concerne
alexandre viala et vincent kraz et il ya
donc trois nouveaux noms maintenant
qu'ils sont a ajouté le colonel lavergne
maintenant général lavergne également
alexis et colère 1 le secrétaire général
de l'elysée et patrick strzoda le
directeur de cabinet de l'élysée pour
eux il n'y a pas véritablement de faux
témoignage mais c'est entre les lignes
que leurs témoignages se ne concordent
pas et c'est en cela que le rapport est
très intéressant et on va pouvoir le
décortiquer tout au long de la journée
sur publicsenat.fr
et dans nos éditions futures mais à
chaque fois les sénateurs je vais vous
montrer
ils ont établi sur sur chacun des points
très précisément que ce soit par exemple
sur elle et fonctionne avec sont bénins
et bien il ya sur chaque paragraphe ce
que chacun des trois personnages a pu
dire qui ne concordent pas avec les
déclarations des uns et des autres et
comme cela sur les fonctions comme cela
également sur et bien elle est ce qu'il
a pu faire au sein de la sécurité a dû
prendre un public et également sur
d'autres points il ya cette page comme
ça d' incohérences contre lyon ans mais
maintenant c'est effectivement la
justice merci à vous content jean pierre
sueur ça vous a fait réagir aussi à les
propos de rares berger porte parole du
parti présidentiel a dit ça crée un
dangereux précédent c'est de la
politique
une réaction très rapide il ya vraiment
je ne suis pas d'accord
mais non il qu'est ce que vous voulez
ils n'ont pas pu faire à l'assemblée
nationale une commission dans lequel
tout simplement parce qu'ils l'ont voulu
ils sont restés dépendant du pouvoir
exécutif
le parlement n'a de sens que s'il a une
certaine indépendance à l'égard du
pouvoir exécutif bien sûr on peut avoir
des solidarités mais quand il s'agit
d'une commission d' enquête
parlementaire
ce n'est pas un acte politique est
vraiment c'est une erreur absolue que de
nous accuser de faire de la politique
politicienne pas du tout on est là pour
établir la vérité pour dire qu'il ya des
dysfonctionnements dans l'appareil
d'état qui sont insupportables qui doit
venir sont réformés merci sincère
français n'a lui fait moi je dirais que
c'est une défense de panique
voilà quand on n'a plus rien à dire et
qu'on est gênée on utilise ce type de
comportement c'est très dommage on c'est
très dommage
merci ben talal buffet merci elles ont
bien fait remercie quentin un calme et
font de cette émission spécialement
continuent à analyser ce rapport
sénatorial dans nos différentes
émissions à 16h30 et 18h30 à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]